à à
Ừ
rồi
vừa rồi Tôi muốn nhìn thấy không có ai
xem mà tự nhiên có một là thích hơi ảo
diệu
Anh ở ngoài hai người bị giật Tít cái từ
hacking như vậy
Ai biết đâu hôm nay ở lợn xe máy đủ để
đột biến gọi
anh alo alo
hôm nay thời ta là mình cũng muốn chia
sẻ tâm sự nhiều đấy nhưng mà
đây đây đây mình mới
Ừ mình mới xem xong lại hôm hôm trước là
mình chưa xem video
của mấy buổi trước để mà xem các câu hỏi
tổng hợp lại các câu hỏi thế nên vừa rồi
mình phải xem nhanh lướt qua Tốc Độ 2
chấm Để mà
xem lại tất cả các câu hỏi
Ừ để mà mình tổng hợp lại thế này là bây
giờ thành tl hơi muộn
à Thế bây giờ là bệnh vẫn còn 4 phút để
tôi Tâm Sự ngoại hack thì cuối buổi nhé
nhưng mọi khi thôi đó là mình sẽ chia sẻ
những cái thứ có vẻ hay ho thì mình sẽ
để cuối buổi
cho phù hợp cho việc mấy ông ở cậu người
ông già sữa là mấy ông không Không học
hành gì của tôi nhưng mà Mấy ông vẫn
thích xem mấy cái thứ đấy cuối buổi
người ông vào mà em xem đúng không ạ
anh nói thế Tự nhiên em về được giảm một
nửa thì buồn cười
đầu tiên thì
em tự bây giờ mình ghi tắt quá đôi khi
mình đọc những trang hiệu Hôm trước mình
ghi chữ phốt nó là cái gì nhé
em chẳng hiểu gì luôn
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
Ừ nhưng mà theo như mình lúc vừa nãy vừa
lấy Lúc mà tắm nhưng như mình đã cười
nói đôi khi tắm với nó sẽ kiểu là lúc mà
các bạn chiêm nghiệm ra nhiều thứ nhất
từ điển hình là cách giải quyết Bắc trở
lại hoa dại đôi khi không phải bất ở
trong lập trình đúng ạ đôi khi đó là bốc
trong cuộc sống nó cuộc sống các bạn có
rất nhiều cái bất mà gọi không được biết
cách thì giải quyết là như thế nào
thì à
Không tôi đi phút ở đây không ám Chị ở
về Phúc trường cũ đâu bởi vì à Thật sự
thì tôi Tôi từng nói rồi đấy tôi sẽ
không muốn nói xấu về nơi cũ mình đã
từng làm việc
nó không nó thể hiện mình không chuyên
nghiệp lắm đi
à à Nhưng mà tôi nhớ nhưng mà tôi vừa
nãy rồi đi làm mấy thì tôi đang định nói
lại tôi đang định chia sẻ Bùi hôm nay sẽ
buổi tối tự nói xấu bản thân ở thì cứ
cho nó ra phốt bản hơn thì cũng được ạ
32 phút hiện báo chí con ok bắt đầu nhé
Thì như tội từng nói đó là tôi cảm thấy
rất dị ứng từ thầy vì thực vốn dĩ mình
không phải con người hoàn hảo mình lắm
tật cũng như là rất nhiều cái xấu thì
thì cái cái vụ mà tôi đang định nói với
nói xấu về chính bản thân mình đó làm
chị là thế là nói thật thôi Bởi vì tính
tôi thì tôi từng nói rồi đó tôi quan
điểm về cây ngay không sợ chết đứng làm
gì ở mình sống thật với bản thân mình
biết được và mình mạng yếu mình có những
điểm và ưu điểm là gì
A và đương nhiên rồi chắc chắn không thể
hoàn hảo để cả không có việc điểm mình
chỉ biến được một vài cái ngược đĩa mình
thành ưu điểm thì nó là cái tốt giống
như kiểu tôi bảo với tôi Tôi bảo là tôi
nói nhiều em ạ thì tôi biến nó thành yêu
bằng cách là tôi sẽ nói những cái thứ mà
mọi người
thích nghe thì sẽ nó sẽ là ưu điểm nhưng
mà ngoài ra nó sẽ có rất nhiều cái những
điểm của tôi mà tôi nghĩ không biết sẽ
sửa được không Có khi ở khó mà sửa nó
điển hình giống như là tôi thường ra làm
con người
ờ ờ
Ừ nếu mà điểm và kiểu nó ngắn gọn thì có
thể là có thể cho là cổ phủ giờ ra chưa
Nếu nói ngắn gọn kiểu như thế đấy với
nhiều người một vài người từng nói Tôi
Thế một vài người thì cứ nói không là
tôi cứ cứ cho là Ừ tôi nói đại khá như
thế Tại sao Bởi vì cô hủ đây không ám
chỉ tôi không không tiếp thu được cái
mới mà có những cái mà tôi cảm thấy á Nó
vốn dĩ nên nên là thế
Ừ cái này ra không biết giải thích nhà
nhưng tôi thử ví dụ ví dụ một cái nha sẽ
dễ ví dụ của tôi là một thằng con trai
cô hồn theo cả là tôi sẽ thích những cái
truyền thống thích những ví dụ là con
gái thì nên để tóc dài con trai nên để
tóc ngắn vẫn có con trai nên tóc dài con
gái nó dại cái sự thế anh nói thế nhưng
có vậy bạn kiểu tóc ngắn xinh thì mình
vẫn thích nhưng mà đã nói đấy đấy có đặt
một cái điển hình của thôi nó làm cái sự
cố hữu Đó là ví dụ là con trai thì phải
như thế nào và con gái thì nên như thế
nào chả thế
một vài người ở đây Nếu giờ sự mà kiểu
đấu tranh cho Quyền mình làm dấu thì sẽ
rất kể cậu ấy của tôi nhưng mà tôi mà
thấy có phải phân biệt nam nữ ngắm gì ở
ví dụ con trai thì không nên kiểu
Tình yêu đối khóa trả lại
Anh
đối với tôi với mấy thằng năm Nhi thì
đôi khi nói như thế tóc thôi Bây giờ
đang dài đấy lưu ý rồi dài như kiểu con
gái chứ không phải dài kiểu là để đuôi
cái gì đó
mục tiêu chuẩn kép không tiêu chuẩn kép
và là thôi Tôi từng nói về cái khái niệm
tiêu chuẩn két rồi chứ thằng kép là khi
mà bạn có quyền áp đặt cho người ta mà
người ta không quên em đạt lại cho bạn
thì đấy mà tiêu chuẩn kép con tôi yêu
cầu các bạn như nào Ví dụ tôi yêu cầu
cập bạn gái tôi như này cả năm là bạn
gái tôi lại yêu cầu lại tôi phải như thế
Ừ thì tôi vẫn sẽ chấp nhận thì đấy không
được tính tiêu chuẩn ghét đi
à Còn tiêu chuẩn kép ở đây cậu anh được
phép làm thế mà em không được phép làm
thế thì đấy mới là tiêu chuẩn kép
khi con nuôi việc mà
bà cái việc ra trưởng như tôi vừa nói
thì làm trẻ Bởi vì tôi là một con người
kiểu nói một là một máy hai quan điểm
tôi rất không hẳn đã rất khó thay đổi
nhưng nói chung nhà mình đối với tôi nó
là con người có chính kiến thiếu cả là
mình sẽ mình rút ra những bài học kinh
nghiệm gì đó mình sẽ mình sẽ đặt ra
những cái cẩu quy tắc không được phép
làm này không được phải là người kia nói
chung là đội tôi từng xem nhiều video
điển hình là video giờ transporter Người
Vận Chuyển
mở ra đấy phim hành động thôi nhưng mà
cái cái cách của cây anh đấy ở trong
phim đấy Kiểu rất là kiểu nam tính theo
kiểu lại có những quy tắc riêng rồi tôi
bị kiểu cuốn hút bởi thế với tôi nghĩ
làm quý ông một cộng một người đàn ông
thì phải làm chia có những cái quy tắc
riêng của mình có gì biết dịch cả thế
đương nhiên ở đường ở trong Cái phim đấy
Nếu không thấy đó ông ấy về sau mới cũng
bị thay đổi quy tắc bởi một đứa con gái
những người anh hùng không qua nổi ải mỹ
nhân có nhưng mà nhưng mà nó sẽ có
trường hợp ngoại lệ như thế không sao
nhưng mà Ngoài ra thì chúng ta cũng nên
đập những cái quy tắc riêng của mình
ở những cái kiểu tiêu chuẩn những cái
gọi nhé
từ thước đo này không gọi tiêu chuẩn này
nói chung là danh Rối các thứ thứ để mà
mình không hợp vi phạm mà mình luôn Tuấn
heo nó mình biết được cái gì là đúng để
mình làm cái gì sai mình nhé Không ạ
nhưng mà chính vì như thế anh ra là khi
mà nói chuyện này đó thì tôi sẽ nói cái
kiểu là thôi sẽ hiểu
em có tía mặt Kiểu cái chết Khi lắp đặt
người ta lạ là kiểu
Ừ cái này tôi cho con là đúng ông và sẽ
tranh luận cảm tương đối gặp không về
Nội chửi nhau cãi nhau nhưng mà đổi rồi
tôi sẽ bảo vệ quan điểm của tôi nên là
nhiều người sẽ cảm thấy là
có những thứ có những thứ thì nhiều
người sẽ coi nó khá là bình thường là bỏ
qua được còn tôi thì tôi vẫn sẽ hiểu chị
luận về nó anh ra nhiều người sẽ bạn ở
kéo thằng Hai có gặp lại được em
ông bà ngoại ra nữa còn một thêm một cái
nữa là chắc À bởi vì à chả do môi trường
cũng như ạ Nói chung nhiều như tố thì nó
Tôi hơi bị vô tâm một tí
cậu không biết đồng cảm cảm xúc của
người khác đương nhiên vô tâm đây không
ám chỉ tôi không vừa khóc không bao giờ
cậu có cảm xúc với Xem phim buồn là sự
khác Bình thường vân vân Nhưng mà em chỉ
ở
mức độ đồng cảm của tôi không hẳn cao
lắm
cho nên hàng ra là à và và còn thêm
người nữa là ví dụ điển hình Bây giờ tôi
đang tốn thời gian với mấy ông này
anh đúng không dùng từ tốn thời gian thì
tại sao phải dùng tốn thời gian thực ra
tôi vẫn đang làm việc có nghĩa họ ích
anh đúng không Không tối sự dặm đang
bình thường thôi thì
Ừ nhưng mà cái quan trọng tôi nói dùng
từ tốn thời gian bởi lắm chị ạ là với
quan điểm của truyền hình mẹ tôi hiện ạ
Đó là tại sao mày không làm dành thời
gian lại làm kiếm tiền ai cái gì đó
chẳng hạn thế mày Ăn tốn thời gian kiểu
kiểu ra chẳng tràng giải quyết vấn đề gì
cả ông ạ là lo chuyện bao đồng không nói
chuyện nhà kiểu thế đấy
thì thị đấy đấy đấy và tôi cậu không làm
việc nhà tôi đi lo chuyện bao đồng Cờ lo
chuyện cộng đồng nói chuyện mọi người
khác từ Huế và tôi cũng vô tâm có thể
dùng từ vô tâm thì cả các dạng ví dụ là
được à
ạ Bây giờ ở với vợ hay ở với người yêu
có thứ thứ
Ừ thì mình đã không làm hộ phụ việc hộ
cho họ vân vân nóng lạnh mình ngại kiểu
chỉ cần làm theo đam mê của mình yêu thế
lo chuyện bao đồng nóng lạnh ông Nguyễn
Thành dao kéo Suga cái đấy tôi nghĩ có
mở lời khuyên cho mấy bạn nữ chẳng hạn
Nếu bạn nữ rồi tôi không biết bạn làm
ngơ à nhưng đại khái nó kiểu nếu mà các
bạn yêu một người mà giỏi Tôi phải dùng
thường giỏi Tôi không biết tôi rọi không
nhưng mà giỏi thành công thì có ghệ là
họ sẽ đi cùng với việc họ sẽ bật công
việc đúng không ạ
Anh bận công việc hơn hơn tập trung của
bạn bởi vì làm gì có thời gian rảnh để
mà tập trung vào bạn
ông ngoại đây là nhiều bạn thì có thể
nghĩ rằng nhà
rất
nhiều bạn vẫn nghĩ là kiểu yêu người yêu
kiểu
Ừ giỏi giang ngồi kiểu nhiều người biết
đến nổi tiếng thì các bạn không hề biết
rồi mặt trái của nó đúng ạ quên mất cái
mặt trái của nó đón chị là có khi thời
gian anh đấy dành cho người khác nhiều
hơn dành cho Minh nó nhọn
Vì thế nên là thử gà tội nghĩ về câu nói
Không biết ông đi câu nói cậu đang sau
người đàn ông thành công khi làm người
đàn bà gì gì đó nghe có về chưa ạ
chỉ có tại khá như thế Hôm nay tôi ăn
muộn à Tôi chia sẻ cũng hơi muộn thông
cảm với ông không gặp mình nhé Có gì cứ
bộ hệ bù bằng mấy cái chia sẻ khác sau
Okay tiếp theo tôi định nói thêm một cái
mà nốt điện nốt đi về cái làm việc
chuyên nghiệp tôi nói cái này bởi vì à
Tôi thấy thật là
cứ môi trường nào tôi gặp tiền bây giờ
khi tôi thấy vẫn có nhiều người làm việc
theo kiểu vẫn chưa đủ chuyên nghiệp đỡ
nhở tôi vẫn sẽ có
à à à
Ừ tôi cũng sẽ có nhiều cái kiểu vẫn chưa
thực sự tốt nghiệp nhưng mà với cấp độ
nhìn của tôi thì có khá nhiều người cậu
có những cái mà tôi cảm thấy mày cái cơ
bản họ vẫn trước chứ nhỉ
ừ ừ
Anh chuyên nghiệp ở đây gà đôi khi nào
Rất là mấy cái đơn giản tôi cảm thấy là
nó như sau kiểu thứ nhất là nếu không bờ
nên nhắn tin vào trong một nhóm chat tập
thể điều thì của công ty hạn về mấy cái
kiểu
về chuyện riêng cá nhân của ông hoặc à
chị đệ tác một người bất kỳ vào trong cả
cái nón riêng và tất cả mọi người cùng
với xem tôi thấy điều đấy ở rất nhiều
công ty cả không thích nói rồi mà chưa
chưa công ty nào tôi chưa gặp thành phần
bị hết
ở nhóm chat của cả tập thể tự nhiên mấy
ông thay vì ngồi nhắn tin riêng cho nhau
kiểu sợ bị sở kiểu mọi người không biết
đến mình đang làm việc có phải nhắn tin
vào trong nhóm chat của cả công ty tác
riêng hai người hai người nói chuyện
nhau thôi nói chuyện hỏi một vài câu
thôi chuyện dài vãi chưởng choice hết
tin nhắn quan trọng nói trên chẳng hạn
đấy
em ngồi đó đi à
cả
đấy một cái cái thứ hai tương tự đó là ở
công ty tôi hiện tại hiện tại thì cũng
cũng có kiểu nó giống kiểu scoms tất cả
kiểu là là Họp hàng ngày gì mà học hàng
ngày vào buổi sáng buổi sáng tầm 10 15
phút cả cả công ty để mà cậu bạn bạn qua
xem là hôm qua đã làm được những gì còn
còn những vấn đề gì hôm nay tiếp tục làm
là cái gì bà câu hỏi nhưng mà cần trả
lời mỗi người trả lời nhanh
Ừ thế nhưng mà cái cái việc Trả lời
nhanh Đấy nó đi vẫn quá đà vãi
rất nhiều kiểu gọi là 10 15 phút Và thậm
chí là bao nhiêu lần hai thôi nhờ ít
nhất là 2 lần có một ông ở
làm cùng tôi thì nó Ông ấy rất là cục
ông ấy hay bằng tục của ông ấy giữa cục
ông ấy kiểu mấy lần ông này đã từng nói
với phòng cái xếp đó cả cái việc học
mình nó không
không đúng được như ý nghĩa mục đích Họp
kiểu học nhanh bởi vì mang tiếng 15 10
15 phút nhưng mà đã có những cái người
khiến cho cuộc họp đấy nó thành ra thành
30 phút rồi vẫn chưa xong bởi vì người
ấy bà này cái thứ mà thực ra chẳng ai
khác cần nghe rủ hai người để bàn với
kiểu cách hệ thống cần phải hoạt động
như thế nào với Vân mà rõ ràng chỉ có
mỗi sếp của những người ấy hiểu là đang
nói vấn đề gì những anh em kỹ thuật ca
không làm về lĩnh vực Ừ cái gì cả trắng
ạ Hai người đấy còn cãi nhau cơ xảy ra
được rồi nó nó là thiếu chuyên nghiệp
không ạ
anh nói chung là không biết được mọi
người thì quan điểm thế nào nhưng mà
tính tính tôi tôi đã bảo rồi Tôi thường
anh rất tùy ý là mình có làm ảnh hưởng
đến người người khác không tôi sẽ rất kỹ
những cái việc làm ảnh hưởng người khác
à
Ừ ok vào tâm sự xong khá nhiều hi vọng
là mình nói thế xong các bạn là mình em
mong riêng cái Mọi khi tâm sự thì đôi
khi mà các bạn nghe thích thì nghe không
thì thôi ông ạ Nhưng riêng cái vừa rồi
thì mình mong là các bạn nên nên khi ở
xem xét lại xem chính bản thân mình đã
kiểu có những cái tác phong gì đó thiếu
trách nhiệm trong công việc thì nên sửa
nó ngọn không
100 kiểu dạng là kiểu
làm ảnh hưởng đến mọi người ảnh hưởng
tập thể bởi
cho ví dụ như mình mình không cục đến
nỗi là mình sẽ mình sẽ nói thẳng với với
mọi người là kiểu mọi người trật tự đi
Hãy thức
nhưng nhưng mà kiểu có nhiều cái thật là
không không nên nói mà mình phải tự
chiêm nghiệm đúng ạ
ở đầu tiên bây giờ mình sẽ trả lời câu
hỏi nhé hôm bảo vệ có livestream anh
không cũng bảo vệ thì có và Chính vì ở
có và kết hợp việc là mỗi nhóm sẽ có bảo
vệ trong vòng 15 đến 20 phút có thể hơn
[âm nhạc]
con chó nhưng lại tìm được cái gì đó
Nguyên túi Đợi mình tí
[âm nhạc]
không không đánh nó đau nhưng mà cũng
phải rõ nói
Ừ
ok
tiếp theo là đây mình đang nói dối ở đó
là có bảo vệ sẽ có
trong vòng 15 đến 20 phút
à à
Ừ thế thế nên là các bạn cũng sẽ phải
bảo vệ không hẳn là phải bảo vệ nhanh
nhưng mà nói chung mà các bạn phải chuẩn
bị chứ không có người lên kia chào mọi
người xong rồi đi xuống nóng ạ Các bạn
sẽ phải nói cũng cũng sang thăm tâm lý
đi là có nhóm thì sẽ phải bảo vệ Có thể
lâu hơn nếu mà giờ sửa nhóm Á
em có hai cái thứ để khiến nó các bạn sẽ
bảo vệ lâu hơn 1 là
khi các bạn làm ổn quá phải hỏi thêm vài
câu để mà nấm điểm Hay ở các bạn làm dở
quá phải hỏi thêm vài câu để gỡ điểm để
đó đấy Nên là sẽ nó sẽ kiểu không thể
hôm nay cố định thời gian được không ạ ạ
a tiếp theo
em có bạn nhé Phải vụ offline thì mình
thực ra đang dịch lại mình không thể hứa
hẹn bất kỳ cái điều gì cả Ừ
nhưng mà mình cũng rất mong người việc
là lý tưởng nhất thì đó là hết Tết năm
sau
à à
Làm sao đâu nhỉ Ok hết trăm năm sau mà
dịch đỡ hơn rất nhiều vậy thì chị ạ
à à con con mèo nó đò quan mà mình thấy
sủa lần này gắt quá mình cứ phải mình cứ
nghĩ là có người lạ à à
anh
đợi mình đi đi nó lại đánh nhau Con mèo
ú
ừ ừ
à à
Ừ Ok Ok xong rồi gọi Tuấn hơi nhiều thời
gian thôi gửi mấy cái vụ đây
thì mình cứ tưởng cậu nó sủa thấy người
lạ thật thì có trộm vào nhà cho thấy nó
sẽ gặp lại nó là hôm nay nó bảo hơn mọi
khi nó đi Đuổi đuổi con mèo rồi nó đánh
nhau với mèo đương nhiên là
Ơ con này chỉ được cái mồm thôi thì nên
là con con mèo cà do cái hoa nó chạy vào
Okay tiếp theo
mình nói vụ offline
offline là kiểu Ý
I
love light là mình mong là hết Tết âm
thì
Ừ nếu mà nếu mà ổn thì có thể mình sẽ
bay vào trong Sài Gòn một chuyến và mình
sẽ đăng thông báo ở trong trái tim
computer Và chắc là trong phải discord
luôn gì mà kiểu tổ chức offline cho các
bạn để ngoại
Ừ hi vọng ở gần đấy không giống như các
lần trước lần trước là hình như là sau
cái đợt dịch nên là mọi người cũng đang
rất là thoải mái lên đấy à Nhờ đăng ký
và không thể lường trước được thành ta
Offline lần này lên thì hơn 200 gần 300
người thì ra là không có một cái À à
em không có một cái giờ quán cafe nào
lúc đấy tải được gửi thức à Thế là lần
đấy nó hơi bị Hơi bị nhiều không lường
trước được vì mọi khi tổ chức toàn kiểu
có muốn tối đa 50 lần lần đấy đã chuẩn
bị quán cà phê có thể chứa 100 người rồi
nhưng cái cùng nó lên hàng hơn 200 người
với con người phải chuyển qua kiểu di
chuyển địa điểm vài lần 2 rơi rụng gần
hết hơi buồn
ở Hà Nội Hà Nội giờ ra là mình ở đây nên
thành ra là nó lại thoải mái hơn nên là
là chung mình mình muốn là thiệu sau
dịch Thì mình định mình mình sẽ có có
việc vào đấy nên là mình sẽ vào đây
trước sau đó thì
ạ sau đó thì mình thoải mái ở Hà Nội mà
ngoại mình có thể tổ chức ở Hà Nội sau
được
mình đang thở vì mình vừa phải đuổi nhau
con chó mà
chó thì cứ bị nó cơ sủa rồi nó cứ chạy
đuổi nhưng mà thôi à
ở Hà Nội nói chung vào kéo mong bước
dịch cả hai thôi Nói chung là phải thực
sự là kiểu mình thì đương nhiên là các
bạn không biết chắc các bạn không biết
người được ở với cái dịch này chuẩn mà
nó sẽ không bao giờ hết mà nó sẽ kiểu
gần như là sẽ Mình phải sống chung với
nó kiểu dạng nó cũng vật có thể ra kiểu
thịt khoảng bụng lại giống dở h501 thì
có thứ bởi vì cái này con virus nó không
phải diệt tận gốc được
vì sao giờ thật góp nó là nó sẽ cam phát
triển lên ở chung các bạn đấy do các bạn
tất cả để vậy nên tiêm vắcxin
Khi nào giống như kiểu viêm gan vắcxin
bất cứ gì đó để hỗ trợ miễn dịch đi
ngoại
mà cho vào khi nằm ở kiểu mình cảm thấy
thực sự ổn và nó không phải một thứ mà
kiểu khiến cho chúng ta phải kiểu dáng
là nguy hiểm như bây giờ nóng Bạn đừng
chờ đến tay các Miền Tây Mọi người đã
sống bình thường lại với nó rồi vẫn có
vẫn có ca thôi nhưng mà nó coi như là
cần một cái bệnh cũng tương đối nặng thì
hội chứ không phải là bệnh nguy hiểm thế
kiểu cứu dính vào là chết
Ừ ok cái cách lưu ký tự
em dấu nháy
xin lỗi như này không ạ thì à
à Hôm trước có bạn hỏi mình nói chung À
thì ra đôi khi mình sẽ đội các bạn để
hỏi thì mình mới trả lời
nó là như thế này
Tôi
muốn tắt này đi nha à
Ê mày không thấy mấy cái này cái gì mày
chính hôm trước tôi tại hết toàn bộ cái
cốt của mày không về Cha tôi phải chuyện
thư mồ côi đợi thì cho chuyện cốt của
tôi à
Ừ
tôi Clone về tí tội sẽ hướng dẫn mọi
người dùng kích Pháp luôn
thì mình sẽ là hạ một thư mục nữa là di
tru được
hôm nay
à à
ở đây mình sẽ thử muốn vào bên admin sau
đó thì nghỉ
thêm một cái sản phẩm đông lạnh
thì mình sẽ tichchu chấm test lại được
này à
à à Quên à
Ừ thôi Mình gọi localhost cũng được có
hot này
lại đi Chu này
ở
đây xơ mình vào Vietnamese
sổ đỏ và bền vô đắp này
Bây giờ mình thêm một cái sản phẩm
thì mình sẽ đặt tên nó là
iPhone Sky
[âm nhạc]
Chị Thơ điện ảnh
này thằng cái anh
Ừ anh ở bớt nhạy cảm nhé
Ừ anh phải đi xuống mấy ông phải quay
đầu đi ok quay màn hình nhìn không ạ
Ảnh như này
các bạn thêm
Ừ anh Thế mà bây giờ này nó sẽ lỗi nó
không hiển thị thông báo lỗi thôi nha
Bây giờ tôi thử cho mình xem nhé
Đây này
cho mình xem letter bay mình biết được
không ạ ạ
à à
Mà tại sao nó lỗi bởi vì trong cái cái
tên tôi và đặt nó có giống nhái mà giàu
nháy ở trong msword nó hiểu nó là chỗ
hiểu ông ạ sẽ đóng lại trỗi
anh trai Minh bị đỏ da từ tế Xem Tại sao
ta lại bị đau ở
Anh nghe mà
à à
ê ê
Ừ chiều mai ông nhớ cái code Apple nhờ
sẽ là kiểu như này không ạ
thì các bạn thấy biến Các bạn truyền vào
giống kiểu lên như này hay cái gì đó
Ừ anh em này cái gì đó như thế này và
ở tại Mỹ Thọ cho bạn xem trên ebay đã
đóng góp
ctv02 có mạng mà chỉ có 5 sản phẩm không
ấy có cái thằng iPhone Skies kia bây giờ
mình thử die Croatia ra này
khi mà các bạn câu fe0 chặn được thì các
bạn nên cậu đang là ra như này sau đó
thì các bạn copy cốt vào ở trong cái này
còn một vài syo này các bạn copy hàng
Cốt và này sau đó thì ấn Gold sẽ sẽ báo
về lỗi ở tại răng nào thức à ngay ở đây
nó báo lỗi này bị lỗi tại cái dấu nháy
chính là dấu nháy đây này Nó ngoại nghĩa
là chuẩn ra cái nháy tất cả các bạn vẫn
muốn đi rất là không ạ Các bạn Sky rất
thích muốn thêm phải và chặn lại mình
làm như thế nào thì mình lưu lại được
vào dấu nháy mỗi ngày đơn như là họ nhảy
kép chẳng hạn cũng được chỉ còn cách là
mình sẽ phải thêm xấu ruột cháu đang
trước như thế này nếu các bạn còn nhớ
thì cá sấu chéo này sẽ thể hiện việc là
Ừ nó nó hiểu là cái này nó sẽ chỉ mang
tính chất ở một ký tự không nó không có
một cái ý nghĩa đặc biệt với cả các bạn
nhớ về học phí cách này cũng từng nói
qua bọn này đấy ạ Còn nếu mà các bạn mà
không có rồi nhà như này nó sẽ hiệu nhái
có ý nghĩa là kết thúc của cây chuối là
nó bị lỗi cách để mà các bạn thêm cái
đấy vào thì không phải là các bạn sẽ sửa
vào các bạn tình trong chuỗi xem có nháy
không Rồi các bạn thêm vào không làm như
thế mà cách tốt ở đây và cũng như để
phòng chống về cả apidexin Có rất nhiều
u cổ có trống tương đối rồi rất nhiều
cách để trồng thêm việc chèn thêm nghị
kí tự đặc biệt vào khiến cậu ashworth
các bạn chết hoặc ta nó chạy sai thì họ
sẽ thêm cái hàng nếu các bạn không nhớ
từ tên của Hàn còn nhớ thứ quá nó là ác
flash in string p stressed gạch chéo đều
ngoại và sẽ có hàng xe tải Hà mày sẽ ra
sao nó sẽ là kiểu nó sẽ thêm gạch chéo
vào trước những những cái phí tự đặc
biệt để màn gì ở ký tự này nó sẽ không
còn ở đặc biệt mà chỉ ở đây là ký tự
thôi là giống như theo ký tự chữ bình
thường thôi để ngoại
Ừ đấy các bạn thêm vào mọi cái nhà cho
chắc ra những cái khác này chỉ có thể
lại nó không sao cả
a a file Không cần đâu phải không cần
anh cùng ai ai đi ra là không cần đâu Ở
đâu ai đi vẫn thể hack hay đi chắc vẫn
có thằng ngồi ngon nó thêm dầu ngày đóng
nháy luôn thêm tí mình dậy các bạn ấy
các em rất chân tình của bạn sẽ hiểu cái
vụ này hơn
cái nào trong A như thế này
sau đó em mình cứ tải lại trang
anh không báo lỗi đừng oán thôi à Bây
giờ nằm trong báo lỗi gì cả khi chạy thử
này
khi tải các bạn hãy Sky ơi Lên rồi không
ạ Ok đó anh sẽ xong nó bạn sẽ để trước
mắt là các bạn hiểu là có thể Insert
được đã nhưng thực chất là mình vừa nói
thì nó có thể giải quyết được bài toán
chống hát ngoại nhưng màn hình để nhìn
rõ hơn
Ừ ok chưa ạ
vị trí
À hôm nay thức dậy mình hộ mình chắc là
buổi hôm nay mình sẽ rất dài rồi
chỉ mình em mình dùng bàn phím cơ thôi
ở bàn phím cơ blue blue Serie A
I want I can show hôm trước ở có bạn nói
về cái này nó việc thực là cũng một cách
quy tắc để mà kia để mà chọn được nhiều
dòng cùng một lúc để chỉnh sửa nhiều
dòng cùng một lúc
cho bạn nào chưa biết bởi vì là các bạn
nhớ về vụ hôm trước mình làm cái ghế
không ạ Mình mình cho các bạn xem lại bộ
đấy nhé Đây là một cách nhanh hơn rất
nhiều nếu là sửa các bạn trả lời viết
như khách thì da mình thường hay dùng
cái đấy
ở
bài hôm trước đâu nhỉ À
chị sẽ mở lại đây bài hôm trước
à à
anh
nói giống cái tặng dùng đến ai vậy
Ồ không tôi sẽ chơi Cái này đi hay hơn
này
tôi mở em đi thi cho mấy ông xem đề bài
đó gọi E thêm để tìm kiếm mọi thứ rất
nhanh Tik Tok không ạ
thì các bạn nhớ vụ này không ạ Đó là
kiểu hôm trước mình muốn in sợ isis mình
sẽ phải thêm những cái giấu vào trong
cái này nhanh thì có bạn vợ ý là sẽ dùng
mâm ti cao su tất cả như thế này
Xin chào Bình thường mà Mấy ông sữa như
này mới không chỉnh sửa được từng dòng
tại tại cái kiểu vị trí con chó ốm như
này thôi như là mấy ông nghĩ thế nào
việc là mấy ông sẽ chọn được nhiều con
chó cùng lúc sau đó nếu không sửa một là
mấy ông thể chọn là kiểu chọn bằng tay
kia giữ phím Control này thôi chọn tương
dòng ngay để mà cũng sửa như thế này này
Đây là một cách như một cách nữa nhưng
mà tôi không rõ việc là thằng nào so với
cách hỗ trợ không nhiều Tôi sẽ làm ở bên
a
baby store thì tôi thử cho một ví dụ nhé
à à
đã
test chuẩn ppn.em
phụ kiện nhạc
ở đây tôi sẽ giữ phím của nó
Ừ anh đây này
à à
À mà tôi sẽ ấn phím khô mà ngày đầu đầu
dòng này ấn phím em đến đúng rồi em để
đến cuối dòng này đấy hôm để đầu dòng
nha hẹn cuối dòng này xong rồi tôi sẽ có
cách là tôi sẽ giữ phím control
control sau đó thì
ở hà Dùng mũi tên
sau đó thì dùng giữ thêm phím ship xong
rồi dùng mũi tên là như thế này Bôi đen
Cái gì đó nha như thế này đó sôi tôi sẽ
thêm dầu ngày này sau 10 ra như này họa
xong rồi giữ gìn ship với ăn cho bà
không đấy sau đó đi xóa này đi hay dấu
phẩy này tại A
à À thằng kia thì có hai cái kê mình
thấy bỏ qua trường hợp này anh sẽ đến
trường hợp này trước đi Ừ hôm nay anh
đội này này này
đội này
Cho
tôi mua cái này rồi đây này
à à
đi dạo chỉ ở mức tương đối rồi ông ạ
Nghe có vẻ chữ thần kinh kia nó bị thừa
ra một cái khó để chọn
Ừ nhưng mà mày ông hiểu gì tôi bạn nhé
Mình có thể dùng Monte cao su kiểu nghe
được là như thế này
dự án riêng hàng ngày thì ông sửa móng
tay cũng được
nhưng là xong rồi
ở đây đang dùng măng tươi con sôi để em
sửa nha nhiều người ông kiểu thấy nó
ngắn quá thì ông mùi nghĩ ra cách này
mướn để cho cách đấy à
khi dự án được ở Mỹ nhớ phím tắt không
nhớ lắm
Ừ ok đấy cách để dùng công ty cao su
để sau này làm bia không ạ bia Nếu mà
mếu không biết nó bị dính aritech được
nó dịch ra đại Khái ở kiểu Giận à Không
thích Không thích Thị trường vẫn gặp
khách hàng để mà phân tích Xem khách
hàng được sự cần gì hoặc là đôi khi ở
Nếu làm làm sản phẩm riêng của công ty
thiệu công ty làm ra sản phẩm ấy thì năm
nào uống cà phê với Facebook của cậu sản
phẩm công ty đúng không Thì à
chị sẽ khảo sát trên thị trường cần cái
gì cho nó làm chứ không cần phải hỏi
chính xác mục khách hàng nữa đấy thì cái
việc đấy là mình sẽ kiểu giao tiếp với
con người nhiều hơn sau đó mình sẽ tự
ngờ mình có phải biết phải công nghệ để
mình phân tích xem mà mình sẽ cần làm
những cái gì Văn vân vân Nhưng mà thực
ra không cần hiểu rõ về công nghệ lắm
thì phải là áp dụng công nghệ gì cái
ý thì cái vụ 3 này thật ra hồi trước
mình có nghĩ đến bởi vì thì tao biết nói
chuyện với con người cũng có vẻ nói được
đấy mình là một đứa cũng giỏi văn vở thế
mà mình thực ra mình thích về cái vụ lại
BM hơn
thì mình sẽ dùng từ BM buổi sau nhé buổi
này sẽ không kịp cho Hôm nay có vẻ có
khá những thứ cần chia sẻ quá các bạn
kiểm tra thử xem buổi xong Mình định nói
BM với BM nó có giống nhau điểm gì khác
nhau Điểm gì em với ông tra thử cái này
Xem không biết tôi nói với ông chưa
a BM về pm nhé Ok
anh đi làm vẫn phải biết tài liệu hả
thầy hôm trước mình hướng dẫn các bạn về
viết tài liệu của đồn ấy thì các bạn hỏi
là hỏi con này Ừ thì được ah là đi làm
thì à các bạn đốt đôi khi các bạn chỉ ở
động của một phần các bạn sẽ vào mà muộn
quá thì các bạn không đến thời gian các
bạn ngồi biết được cái tình tài liệu nó
làm như thế nào Thế cái ra tao bay cũng
xong hết rồi có thứ các bạn chị nhảy vào
cốc thôi
anh nói chung à Nhưng mà cái việc làm đồ
án Thì mình vẫn muốn dạy các bạn từ đầu
đến cuối để các bạn hình dung được cách
làm cái phần mềm từ đầu đường của nó như
thế nào còn về sau biết đâu các bạn sẽ
xem xét xem mà các bạn thích làm cái nào
hơn là sự còn viết tài liệu hay quá các
bạn cảm thấy thời gian làm tài liệu còn
hay hơn một nước cốt em ạ thì đấy làm
công việc của BIDV đó rất là phân tích
thì nó sẽ tiết tài liệu đấy đúng không ạ
thì
cho con Nếu mà giờ sửa các bạn thích về
cái vụ làm làm thiết kế cơ sở liệu đấy
thì sẽ nhảy sang có rất nhiều đúng không
ạ Cái cái mà mình đang dạy làm kế đồ án
nó không chỉ các bạn làm một bác em nội
ngoại các bạn làm từ a đến z toàn bộ của
một cái xanh thoát ngoạn các bạn có phải
quy trình cơ mà không ạ thì việc thì
công việc đấy nó sẽ rất là nhiều nhưng
mà đi làm thực tế thì các bạn sẽ chỉ làm
một phần trong đấy này nếu mà Đấy đấy nó
ra còn tùy Nếu mà sự ông vào một công ty
áp vì có khi ông phải làm nhiều hơn thế
a
tiếp theo thuật toán anh còn dùng không
có thể thực ra là kiểu thực tế thì các
bạn đôi khi hay lo ngại được các bạn Dốt
toán cũng nhờ các bạn không chưa học
nhiều về thuật toán thì các bạn sinh lại
được đi làm thực tế đi làm đương nhiên à
các bạn sẽ sinh thỏa sẽ phải làm những
cái để giải quyết một cái gì đó bằng 1
cái thuật toán nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà thực sự thì rất nhiều lập
trình viên không rõ kiểm toán tiền hình
mình đang ngồi ví dụ
Ông sếp của mình là người rất giỏi thuật
toán thì sẽ giải quyết bài toán minh hơn
còn mình không toàn thể tỏa nên mình làm
đôi khi là nó hơi bị nặng về việc cách
xử lý bài toán của mình nhưng mà sẽ có
những cái anh đi trước có những Anh
chuyên dọn nó chơi chưa giỏi Toán thì hỗ
trợ mình vụ đấy thì các bạn không cần
nhất thiết phải giỏi toán mấy vụ này đâu
là chỗ nào chỉ cần có tư duy lôgic một
tí được tiếp theo về vụ chia sẻ tài liệu
do vừa nãy mình cũng đẩy ra một ý tưởng
này rất là hay
ở đó là bây giờ tôi biết phần thưởng cho
mấy ông khi bảo vệ đồ hóa thành công
tương đối Nó là gì rồi ông ạ đó là ngoài
việc là mấy ông được gặp mặt rồi Bó tay
tôi thì cái hay cái không phải tôi người
nổi tiếng như nhưng mà sẽ là kiểu tôi sẽ
ở
a cho vài nhóm một vài cái tài liệu mà
tôi mất tiền tôi tự bỏ tiền ra mua
đứng yên thời ta cũng không nên lắm Tôi
khuyên mày ông là nên kiểu ở cây sau
kiếm được tiền đi làm được vọng kiếm
được tiền thì mày ông nên
mua mua mày có học ngồi ta không ạ để mà
kiểu nói chung là mình mình là dân về
à cậu mình dân làm về trí óc nó ngoạn
những cái gọi là
Anh khỏe chứ sáng không ạ thì mình cũng
nên tôn trọng chất sáng người khác mình
em bỏ tiền là người ta nhưng mà nói
chung là đại khái tôi sẽ chia sẻ trong
mấy ông phải trả tài liệu thôi à
Ừ tôi Cậu đã mua
tài liệu và trục đô trên 100 đô nhưng mà
cũng cũng tương đối quý rồi nếu không
béo đi làm mà không có thêm những cái
thời liệu đây thiếu về ở cậu mấy ông sẽ
sẽ ổn hơn mà không ạ
Tại liệu mất tiền Nó khác gọi lắm ông ạ
a tiếp theo
anh ta Martin rồi Bác Đinh về không có
bạn hôm trước nói mình về cái vụ giao
diện này mình
khi mình thực ra là lúc mà mình dậy rồi
các bạn với sẽ hết mình khẩu mình quên
không nói đấy em mình cho các bạn xem
qua luôn ngay cái vụ
sự đây trang chủ khách hàng cũng trước
các bạn thấy ở được K ạ Nó bị thừa hoặc
trắng này nếu mà vài người không để ý
thì nó bị thừa hoài chẳng trên là thử
khoảng trắng nó bên trái hay bên phải
nơi đó nó kiểu dạng nằm trong buổi không
ấy thì cách kiểm tra xóa đi Hoàn toàn
những cái khoản Trang đấy các bạn thể sẽ
ở đây các bạn thêm chữ mon body đây này
rồi mang kia là không là ba định là
không thì nó sẽ xóa đi hoàn toàn hoàn
Trang đấy
hai iPhone chẳng chết nữa tôi không Nhớ
lắm đâu trên dùng cái gì nhỉ tôi xem lại
Pháp
những hình ảnh chế Nếu như không sửa
được Thấy nhớ ở ngựa có cách để mà cắt
hỏi thằng trên à
anh
nói chú của tôi thì tôi nói tôi không
chuyên CS Tôi không nhớ lắm rồi vụ này
đâu còn nhớ thì thì thì trả lời hộ tôi
có lấy Pháp à
em
dùng sao á Sao thay thế cho bọn cái nữa
để tôi thử nhé tôi ngỡ như là sao
thì tôi thử đoạn này à
Ừ đúng rồi đúng rồi nó sao Ok Ok
sao là làm một cái
Ừ
bạn cứ nói đi độ hơn sao htl tao có đi
chắc nữa ngôi sao đầy đủ mọi cái sẽ được
rồi
à à
Ừ
ok
tiếp theo nữa Hôm trước và mình có đặt
tên file mình lúc đấy mình đang băn
khoăn không biết đặt tên là gì có bạn để
bảo là đặt tên là cô đắp một mà là tách
ra các bạn khuyên các bạn hồi trước mình
từng đặt tên như thế vô đắp một boss 2
giờ không nên thế bởi vì là tên như là
hơi tôi nghĩa là không hiểu được một
tặng một là gì vô Đắc là gì này cái thứ
và vì sao các bạn hãy quên không biết là
bây giờ đang có đắt mấy ở ngại thế chứ
giờ các bạn nên đặt tên là rõ nghĩa hơn
một tí tiếp theo là các bạn không nên
đặt một cái file test ở trên trang của
mình đương nhiên là các bạn dùng để test
mà nó ngoác nhưng mà các bạn nên để nó
hẳn cho một thư mục người đó và nên kiểu
đặc quyền nó nó các thứ về mình đã từng
thấy vô số trang web vẫn còn để file
test ở trên trang chủ họ và quên xóa đi
thành ra là cậu đưa các bạn vào một
trang web bất kỳ sai Các Bạn anh sữa
trang dantri.com đại khái như thế ở
Thượng sáng có được không
anh ở đấy Kiểu thế mày này nó không có
Nhưng mà nếu hiểu đi du ngoạn rõ nhà tự
nhiên gửi sang cái xanh test của ông nữa
đâu mình cái Trang ở đâu khi nó còn mấy
cái cậu nó cái thông tin nhạy cảm vẫn
như chết nữa ở ngoại đã thành ra Khánh
Nhi à
à à câu này cho ta mình đang mình phải
vất vả bên A bên đồ án
dự đoán đó là các bạn nhắn tin Giả sử có
bạn mà bạn kéo liên lạc với bạn cùng
nhóm kiểu bây giờ đang làm online mình
thành ra là kẻ các bạn cũng không biết
nhau nên là thứ duy nhất các bạn liên
lạc được là qua mạng đột nhiên bạn
chuyện mất tích thì làm như thế nào thì
các bạn lúc đấy các bạn nên chờ đợi một
ngày hơi giống nhiều công an đấy các bạn
thấy một người đó mất tích thì các bạn
ít nhất phải đợi một ngày và cố lên lạc
mỗi người ta mọi cách đã sửa Trả lời vào
trang cá nhân của người ra bình luận bài
đang người ta chẳng hạn từng bình bình
luận kiểu dạng là mày mày chặt thì tao
đi
hay các thứ nữa thì thì
nói chung là để tìm mọi cách để giữ liên
lạc với người ta mà không được thì lúc
đấy báo lại cho mình không ạ chào mào 24
sau 24 giờ nha Cái bên công an làm trình
xử lý thế thôi
à à
khi dùng pp stone ổn không
cài cái pp tôm cái thời Minh vừa mở thì
nói mỗi de bản thân yêu đó sẽ luôn ổn
hơn Editor với nó chuyên nghiệp hơn là
chuyên dùng để tốt hơn
một kẻ nitơ sẽ làm một cái sau tech21
cái nút part 2 một cái Word nhưng thực
ra aiya nó sẽ nặng hơn rất nhiều ngày ra
là kiểu Bạn sẽ cảm thấy vàng đôi khi là
mất phí + vs code thì hiện tại nó không
mất thôi nha các bạn cũng nên cân nhắc
thì dùng qua rồi các bạn sẽ tự trải
nghiệm gì hơn
Ừ Tự Nhiên TP tôm Mất phí thì các bạn
nên dùng merdu để mà thử trải nghiệm thu
vậy Tôi khuyên với ông ấy Ông bỏ tiền ra
kiểu lần lấy tiền để mà thử trải nghiệm
cái đấy không phải thử nữa không ạ ạ
a tiếp theo là có bạn bảo là em muốn bỏ
cái đối tượng tưởng tượng nhân viên đi
em giả sự em làm cái Trang chỉ có một
quản lý thôi được không ạ Tức là cái cái
đồ án này mình muốn dậy cho các bạn nên
có đầy đủ đầy đủ về cái khoản là có cả
nhân viên có quản lý có cả khách hàng
không có tài khoản có khách hàng có tài
khoản để các bạn hình dung toàn bộ đầy
đủ về về cái phân quyền là các thứ thứ
Ừ chứ không nên kiểu các bạn rút gọn đối
tượng đi tính năng các bạn sẽ bị ngắn
hơn cũng như đơn giản hơn
khi nghe các bạn ạ trước khi các bạn làm
một mình tôi sẽ yêu cầu các bạn nhẹ còn
nếu các bạn dặn hai mình thì các bạn nên
làm đầy đủ không ạ
vì vậy Nãy nó
1:48 tôi cũng khá nước rồi đau họng
Ồ vậy à
à mà vẫn chưa thấy bài học mà sẽ tay tôi
nợ anh em hôm nay hơi nhiều Tôi xin lỗi
nhà tôi vẫn sẽ phải
em làm hết ngoãn rồi anh sẽ nói hết Hôm
nay tôi sẽ dậy mấy ông nhưng mà không Để
ý kỹ về cái tiêu đề của tôi đặt nó sẽ là
shining Shinee ngoạn cho tôi tôi chơi
cái từ đấy bởi sai sai nó sẽ bao gồm cả
Sign này sai ạ
size Ao này xài app này
à mà không sao áp nên để điện trước
mỹ nhân dịch được mấy cái này không ạ
thực hiện IELTS 9.5
CF size nhỏ nó sẽ là kiểu ở
An đăng ký đăng nhập đăng xuất nóng lạnh
Nếu tôi nhớ không lầm là như thế đấy thì
Ừ thì tôi sẽ dậy mấy ông đăng ký là cao
nó dễ nó nó nó là kiểu Ý
Ừ nó nó là Kiều bạn chất là nói ít sốt
rồi thôi như là đứng như hôm nay mình sẽ
có mình mình cứ làm cho bên khách hàng
đi đăng ký cho bên khách hàng
Ê mấy ông đừng có làm tính năng đăng ký
cá nhân viên nhé Tôi từng phạt một cái
nhóm mà ủng hộ là cho nhân liên đăng ký
cho bạn muốn làm nhân viên với tôi không
Tôi sẽ điền thông tin nhắn tự nhiên vào
được thôi tự nhiên xóa sản phẩm thêm sản
phẩm mới ra tinh chết giờ bọn mấy ông
mấy ông mà làm tình Nam đang phía nhân
viên Tôi đã dặn thì hôm ấy ông vẫn làm
tôi phạt mấy ông ấy
Vì vậy chưa ạ
đã trải nghiệm khách trải nghiệm tuyệt
vời
a Christmas không ạ
à à
em không ở hội đấy là còn có cái kiểu là
đăng ký làm quản lý cơ
Anh muốn cây cực Huế có ông làm đăng ký
quản lý thôi cậu
chơi kiểu và xóa hết sử nhân viên đi
thật sâu cố cho tự xóa được bạn hơn gấp
xoáy sự nhân viên đi Xóa bản thân rồi
đăng xuất thế cuối cùng trả năng nhờ
được nữa sự ảo ma
ừ ừ
Ừ nếu mày ông cậu cứ làm mấy ông cứ làm
theo cậu là
bị Rập Khuôn Cái gì làm tính năngxem
thêm sửa xóa mày không làm thế thì kiểu
rất là giờ không ạ
Ừ nếu cứ cười tôi tin được vì sao kia có
nhóm bằng dính lần nào sinh viên đội thế
Cứ cười đi
ờ ờ khách hàng của tôi tôi nhớ hôm trước
là mình làm là có những cột nào nhưng
tôi sướng rồi các khách hàng nên mở lại
nha mã này tên ngày sinh này
cái kính này
à Nhưng mà thôi mấy mấy cái mấy cái cột
khác hơi lan man quá thì công tự thêm
sau nha Tôi có thể email mật khẩu cho dễ
đã ông ạ
anh cứ tặng tương đồng thế này
có ai điên nên
thế này
email markeing à
I would i
Nghe bài hát phải chăm mẹ cho mấy ông
đặt mật khẩu rõ ràng tránh bị hack không
ạ Cái là unique cho
em không nói chuyện mà cậu một email
nhiều người đăng ký được chứ giờ trâu
Lúc đăng nhập vào con biết là đăng nhập
vào email thế nào không ạ ạ
các bạn sẽ hỏi câu ra hai đó là kiểu lúc
đầu đương nhiên là không có nhân viên
nào bởi vì nếu mà không làm tính năng ký
các bạn suy nghĩ là không nhân viên nào
đúng ạ Không lúc đầu là trình Cái lập
trình viên mình mình mình sẽ tạo trước
cho ông quản lý một cái tài khoản ở trên
BB để ông đấy vào đấy chị ạ và khuya nữa
ông ấy lên đổi mật khẩu đi chẳng hạn thế
để thành lập trên viên là đỡ kiểu vào
lại thì tài khoản đấy đó ngoại sau đó
thì cái ông quản lý đấy tự thêm nhân
viên của mình thật chứa thêm quản lý
khác về chưa ạ Và cũng cũng có trường
hợp nữa nó có thể xảy ra là hồi đấy ạ
tôi Tôi vừa nãy tôi có nói thêm trường
hợp đó là quản lý vào còn tự xóa được
bản thân thậm chí xóa rồi cả còn minh
khác thành ra để rất là rõ nó
U22 Âu cùng cùng chủ một công ty cùng
ông ấy thích ông kia như một trò đùa
chẳng hạn thế không nên điều đấy xảy ra
không ạ cùng cắt thì các bạn không được
cách chỉnh sửa thông tin người khác
không ạ
để xem thông tin người khác là một thứ
gì đó Nhưng cảm rồi à
Ừ ok Nói chung là bây giờ có cái pho mày
đóng ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ làm tính năng
đăng ký thôi nghĩa là kiểu khi vào trang
khi vào cái này có cái nút là đăng nhập
đúng hoặc đăng nhập đăng ký là Nhạn thế
anh sẽ là mình không giúp mình dùng Law
in nhiều hôm nay mình sai đi science
Fshare được cho Thống Nhất nói nrop
nhưng không nó tắt chỉ còn lock out
a Sign in
Em xài ấp ủ
à à
ở Ai Cập ngay em mình sẽ bao cha nó có
chữ đăng ký ấn vào sẽ nhận sạc ngoài phá
ngoạn
à à
Ừ
đúng rồi Nếu mà Mấy ông không có tí Nếu
người dùng tự tên là Master rồi ạ ạ
à à à à
ở đây sẽ là
không đăng ký đúng ạ ạ
Anh tên à
à à
em Email á
vụ
bắt cóc à
Vì
anh sợ à Đăng ký ý
2000sport à
à à
Anh
đã chuẩn sẽ dậy lên sighup thôi set đúng
không ạ Mua sét pháp cũng được
nhớ mình lỡ đặt theo kiểu dạng chữ vô sẽ
tăng trước rồi chứng nhận đặt bánh trước
Mà sao nghỉ mỗi đã lặn trước rồi Mình
tên heo nhé à à
tiết kiệm ngay
ở đây là tự động điền của tôi vì đây là
kiểu Tôi thường anh điền lưu lại mật
khẩu các thứ mà à
anh em yêu em đua của tôi hồi tôi dậy ở
trường đấy à
à Mà ông nhắn ở đây Giờ không lẽ đi đâu
nhưng tôi bị bay mất nick rồi ok thì lo
gì em ạ chị sẽ đổi đây là à
ô long + gmail.com mật khẩu là 123
Anh Tạm thời thì tôi chưa dậy mấy ông về
mã hóa mật khẩu đâu làm cực đơn giản
thôi nó khi bấm vào đăng ký này Nó sẽ
nhảy cái file đó ông ạ để tạo file này
em học sinh năm nhất à
bộ phim sẽ FPT này
thì mình bỏ qua vụ vay bếp nhá bỏ qua vụ
mã hóa mật khẩu đi tôi làm đơn giản nếu
mà áo kiểu một số tạp lên mấy ông làm
sao
à à
I HT này à
em ở đâu lên mình đang để lên này
để password à
thì
mình sẽ là câu đầu tiên là mình sẽ kết
nối DB ngoại cái quá amin
máy xúc sẹo Connect chấm t-pain
Ừ nhưng mà ở đây Ở đây các bạn sẽ nghĩ
rằng là ok làm đơn giản thôi Chỉ việc
đăng ký là in such vào trong bê thôi mà
nóng ạ như cá nó là sai bởi vì các bạn
nên nhớ là cái vụ là vừa nãy mình có nói
Tại email nên là không trùng đó ngoại
thì có 2 cách để các bạn làm hai cách để
giải quyết bài toán đây nó như thế này
cách đơn giản cách đơn giản nhé đó là
các bạn bởi vì vừa rồi thì ta mình cũng
đã Để Đó là chắc chắn là cái email không
thì chết chung rồi mà thêm cái Uống nước
Cái đây rồi nếu là các bạn chị thì pin
rất vào thôi có bạn kiểm tra xem là khi
Insert Nó mà bị lỗi thì rất là
anh đăng ký có vấn đề có bạn cứ đăng cứ
điều hướng quay lại về thông báo người
dùng để đăng ký vấn đề ngoại là không là
người dùng có thể liên quan việc sai
việc nhập Vinh đa tinh của vấn đề hoặc à
email bị trùng nó ngoại nói chung là đấy
một cái lỗi chung chung thì có bạn có
đều thông báo về là đăng ký có vấn đề
cái thứ hai đó là các bạn sẽ phải đến
xem là vợ chỉ email này trong bảng nó có
có hay chưa Nếu mà chưa thì mình mới cho
phép esop vào nếu có rồi thì mình lại
phải điều hướng về mà đăng ký gồm là
email này bị chung đấy mình thì mình sẽ
dạy các bạn về cách hay về các đấy có vẻ
Nhung nhiều nơi dùng hơn và cái cái
thông báo nó sẽ rõ ràng hơn chứ còn hơn
này việc đấy cơ cấu Insert nào sai các
bạn được thông báo về email của vấn đề
là nó không đúng lắm ừ ừ
Ừ
thì câu SQL mình sẽ là select
mình sẽ đến đúng không ạ Mình sẽ đến xem
mà
user Này
Where email bằng
Email này
tức là mình đến xem à Kiểu cò xuất hiện
email này chưa đúng ạ
Kết quả này
và mình sẽ cần lấy thơm anh còn lấy hoặc
đầu tiên thôi
em ở nhà à
Ê bà tại code Lacoste cao sao á
khi
mình đã đây là đây à number dâu cũng
được mà nếu mà ít nằm proud bằng bằng
không thì mình cho in search Còn nếu nếu
thế thì mình làm cái cùng ngược lại đi
nó bằng một thì mình hiểu hết đầu quay
về thông báo lỗi trước cũng được
location nữa mình sẽ để lại để file size
lắm Tết đây này không Mình kèm thêm cả
lỗi là
à à chung email rồi
các bạn
có thể ấn vào quên mật khẩu hoặc bạn có
thể
đăng nhập ở
anh Mạnh trở lại
mà bạn chắc chứ
ai là yêu
sủa cái này
ừ ừ
Em làm gì mà để chắc cũng làm việc
header của bạn sẽ sẽ dừng lại chạy đấy
luôn thì các bạn sẽ dùng hàng ngày em
ship để trận để nó ngắt ngay cốt tại đây
nó sẽ không ngờ xuống rồi ấy nữa bởi vì
như hôm trước mình nói hết đơ này bản
chất là nó sẽ chèn thêm một cái điều
hướng ở trên đầu trang Nếu các bạn có
thêm hết đầu ở dưới nữa thì nó sẽ định
nó sẽ bị ghi đè lên bằng cái là rồi ấy
chứ không Nó dùng cái biến đấy nó sẽ ghi
đè lên bởi cái ở dưới nó sẽ điều hướng
theo cái dưới chúng mày theo cái ở trên
này đâu chị ạ ở
đây để trong trường hợp mà đăng ký thất
bại ạ dòng họ còn đăng ký thành công thì
mình sẽ là Insert into giờ đúng ạ
e-blue
là kiểu mình sẽ chuyên bao đi sẽ ra tên
tao lên mà ạ
Em email này
a password này ngọn
à à
Âm
Nhạc
và thực ra mình sẽ chỉ cần chạy nó không
quan tâm về quay trở về này
từ trước khi các bạn muốn kiểm tra lỗi
cũng được bạn này kiểm tra lỗi thêm được
ít kiểu mai que o Alo được
ở tại đại khái như thế đó mà cho iCloud
cho chắc nhé nick này xong à
ở đây chạy thôi chạy này
I felt like I
Anh Vietsub
các câu truy vấn nhân của vấn đề
Ừ nếu mà có bạn chạy như thế này mà thấy
bảo như này chúng tôi ở câu truy vấn của
mình đi Em hãy kéo anh Connect để mình
thử 32 câu truy vấn này ra chạy trai chị
xem xem Tại sao Nó bị tật lê
ở trong giấy bình thường không ạ mình
kiểm tra bằng mắt thường mà miễn sao
thấy được không ạ Đúng rồi
ở đây không phải bạn mũ rơm mà bạn có SM
nhờ các bạn có thể chạy trước thế này đã
gấu này sẽ bảo là bà này không đơn giản
này đó
anh em sẽ đổi nó xuất tâm mà ở đó ngon
không phải bảo người dùng mà bạn khách
hàng luôn ạ
khi
đưa các bạn chạy lại phát nữa này copy
cái này nó chạy đây này
anh thấy ổn ổn rồi thì các bạn sẽ xóa
cái đi bạn chạy sang nữa nó không báo
lỗi đúng ạ không báo lỗi tất cả có vẻ
thành công nó sau đó ai Bây giờ các bạn
ấn đến này xem thôi
à Tôi đang dậy Giờ chậm không ạ ra trận
có như ông sẽ mất kiên nhẫn tôi tải lại
sang phát nữa tất cả nó đăng ký cho con
nữa hãy chuẩn ra các bạn nên điều hướng
ở đây khi mà đăng ký xong các bạn điều
hướng về trang chủ là gì gì đó để mọi
người dùng hiểu không nên nhìn trang
trắng ngay và người dùng mà Tại sao phát
nữa là có nhờ đăng kí Highland tái và
thận và lần này nó sẽ thất bại đúng
không ạ - email rồi ai đi Sủa đúng thì
chị Bây giờ mình sẽ có thể in a lỗi nếu
có vấn đề gì đó ở trên này TP này
ít kẽm ngược lại nghĩa là nếu có Hoặc
nếu có hiểu đôla ghét Hero mình sẽ in
cái Rose A1
cho họ ghét Euro II
ừ ừ
Em hãy thêm tí mua mày sau nhé Thì có
bạn
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi có thể dùng ứng dụng sẽ
season nhưng mà thôi Mình mình chưa dậy
các bạn về hôm nay đúng là mình sẽ dạy
các bạn mới sinh
khi được mình sẽ dạy các bạn luôn cả sơ
sinh liên quan việc Hiển thị thông báo
thế này nhá Ok
Ừ
thì thì đầu tiên thì các bạn sẽ phải
chịu ship sân là cái gì đã rồi Hôm nay
mình sẽ dạy các bạn đăng ký đăng nhập
Đúng rồi mình sẽ dạy các bạn về cái vụ
này luôn đó là
season Tức là sao nghĩa là giả sử mà các
bạn bây giờ thì gần như các bạn thấy
hiện yên được các bạn phải đăng nhập rồi
ông ạ
Ừ cái vụ các bạn phải đăng nhập vào một
cái xanh nào đó đã được các bạn nó rất
bình thường rồi và các bạn quên mất đi
người việc à Tại sao Tại sao phải làm
điều đấy
Ừ thì để mình nói lại đó là đương nhiên
ở bây giờ giả sử ở trong Facebook đi
đóng các bạn phải đăng nhập vào tài
khoản của mình để được vào trang của
mình và về được Chỉnh sửa tài khoản của
mình được mang bài trên trang cá nhân
mình không ạ chỉnh sửa mọi thứ thông tin
của mình mà không phải sửa thông tin của
thằng khác đúng không ạ Nói chung là nó
liên quan đến quyền nóng ạ Các bạn thể
quyền chỉnh sửa chính mình đó ngoại đấy
thì thế nên là mỗi người sẽ có một cái
một cái gì đó riêng của chính mình mà
sửa và thường là ý email chưa đủ thì
email nó vẫn còn công khai nhiều người
biết đến nên nó sẽ luôn kèm với mật khẩu
do chứa mật khẩu cấp 2 + chưa nói yêu
cầu cả gửi tin nhắn nó là vừa nãy có bạn
bảo là hai FA đúng không ạ kiểu sắp được
hai bước nó không ạ Có thể ô TP vân vân
Nói chung là để chắc chắn và đấy là
chính là bạn sẽ sử dụng cặp cha chỗ kiểm
tra bạn phải robot 20 ạ Đây để chắc chắn
đấy là bạn thì các bạn mới được ta bà ha
sau khi đang được nhập được Vào ấy thì
bản chất các bạn sẽ hiểu
đó là gia sử gia xử với giờ các bạn hình
dung nhé Bây giờ mình đang có 1 cái máy
các bạn ra quán net thì chẳng hạn cho
con nét đi ho gà Chị dùng máy ở trên thư
viện đi ông ạ
ở cùng làm một cái đường truyền mạng
không ạ Tại sao việc là các bạn đăng
nhập vào Facebook của chính các bạn mà
thằng bên cạnh cũng dùng chung mạng của
các bạn nó không vào được Facebook của
bạn ạ Rõ ràng là bạn đăng nhập vào rồi
ông ạ
khi các bạn đăng nhập vào rồi thì các
bạn suy nghĩ ra là Ừ thì cái thằng và sự
thống server của thằng Facebook nó sẽ
kiểu nó sẽ hiểu được là đã có một cái
máy rồi đó kết nối từ Việt Nam chỉ ra từ
cái thư viện đấy đến cái server vào nó
để đăng nhập được vào tài khoản ngoại
tại sao nó không hiểu được xanh cái
thằng bên cạnh hàng ấy cùng dùng chung
mạng của bạn để mà thằng ấy vào được tài
khoản của bạn không ạ Và thậm chí là các
bạn thấy em ở bằng ẩn danh lên thì nó
lại là một cái
thì các bạn lại phải đăng nhập lại không
ạ Các bạn biết đấy chứ ạ Các bạn đăng
nhập Facebook của Nga là sử mình đây
mình đăng nhập Facebook phải không ạ
nhưng mờ ẩn danh lên thì mình bạn phải
đăng nhập lại đây mình gửi cho bạn xem
luôn chồng với ông nào chưa biết được
đây này thì lại phải đăng nhập lại này
thậm chữa các bạn mở bằng trình duyệt
khác các bạn cũng mạnh phải là nghiệp
lại thì các bạn không thể nói việc là
dùng chung mạng đã có thể lấy được tài
khoản có thể vào được tài khoản người
khác là đang hơi khó không ạ thậm chí ở
dùng chung một cái máy còn đang không
lấy được chưa cả chỉ cần mở cái sinh ra
các đúng ạ là không là hai tài khoản
khác nhau rồi ông ạ thì cái bài toán ở
đây thì có bạn sẽ hiểu được cái việc mà
khi các bạn bạn Đăng nhập xong rồi
anh tính ở lại nhận xong rồi các bạn
không cần phải đăng nhập lại không ạ
đăng nhập xong rồi này ra sự mình đã
Facebook của mình đi cứ cho dễ hình dung
đi mình vào Facebook của mình Mình đăng
nhập rồi không ạ Các bạn thấy mình không
cần phải đăng nhập lại được mà không cần
đăng nhập lại bé thứ nhất thứ hai là
mình vào bất kỳ thời trang nào khác mình
cũng không cần phải đăng nhập lại không
ạ Tại sao như thế bởi vì là khi mà các
bạn đăng nhập xong rồi thì bản chất là
con server của thằng Facebook nó sẽ tạo
cho các bạn một cái khái niệm đó là
season
Tức là nó sẽ lưu lại phiên đăng nhập của
các bạn trên chính máy trên trên chính
trạng server của nó
chị nhớ mạnh nhé trên server của nó để
Ngoại ok tất cả sao tôi làm chỉ là các
bạn sẽ không không nói chuyện đăng nhập
vào rồi các bạn sửa lại cái vụ vụ đăng
nhập để mà đăng nhập vào tài khoản người
khác và xử ở Tôi thấy đăng nhập vào nick
của tôi không được nhiều người theo dõi
này không có ai quan tâm đấy ạ Tôi sửa
lại tên tên cả đăng nhập hàng kiểu Mạnh
Tuấn rồi mới vào được nick của anh đấy
không không chuyện đấy bởi vì À cái cái
season mà nó được lưu trên server của nó
ạ thành ra là cậu chỉ có thằng quản lý
cái server đấy thì nó quyền sửa được cái
này đăng nhập Vậy thôi để còn không thì
ông đăng nhập vào ứng sẽ chỉ vào được
nick của ông thôi nó không vào được ích
của ai Ông không có quyền sửa cái việc
đăng nhập để vào nick của ai
anh méo méo hiểu đến cái đoạn để không ạ
Đấy xong rồi tiếng Nga nhá
tiếp theo là ok thì các bạn thấy ra nó
sẽ lưu lại như thế thêm việc mà định
phân biệt ông là đang đăng nhập hay
không thì như nào thì Star mãi về sau
tôi mới để ý về vụ đấy các bạn sẽ giờ
tôi sẽ mở cái phần mềm nó kì I
khi edit this Cookie này để mấy ông xem
ở đây
a cho tôi mẹ đi có kiểu trên Facebook
của tôi mới nhìn thấy quốc kỳ thôi chết
tôi sẽ thử
đã lưu trong sin khi mà tôi đăng ký
thành công khi nào đăng ký Anh công xong
đối ngoại thôi sẽ
tại một cái sinh sống còn mày không xem
nhé Tôi sẽ tạo xin là tôi sẽ lưu lại là
sự lạ à
Em in xót xa ngoài đó ngoại
em à Thật sự là tôi lừa lại
tên của cái người đang Nhật ở trong
season em ạ Mình sẽ lưu lại tên này như
thế này đăng ký lại nhé
khi lòng hacker
pro a còn Ok tại nhà 123
ở đó như này cho tôi ấn ở trong cái edg
cực kì này không xem nhé
thì nó sẽ có cái khái niệm nó chó Ken
Ừ đúng nhỉ
à Tôi nhớ có phải khái niệm Cookie
season nở thì tải lại Trang và
à À quên quên Đúng rồi
Ừ thôi Tôi tôi sai rồi tôi sạc đoạn này
bảo sao không ra
nếu mà ông mấy ông muốn làm việc ở cái
xứ tử trong TP thì béo phải dùng cái
series Star đã thì mà ông mới làm được
ông phải thêm chữ season II
I start đỏ tôi tôi lâu không dùng ai
thấu quên nội tôi lỗi tôi
làm sao tôi vẫn chỉ trong vòng 10 giây
là tôi nhận ra tôi đã sai không ạ
Vì thế tôi không đăng ký cho nữa thôi
đen vãi thằng kia thằng đấy mưa Ờ tôi
tạm xóa ở rồi hacker Pro hay đi
đây đăng ký phát nữa đó sau đó mình đưa
ông vào ai đi thi cuộc thi này cũng sẽ
đó nó sẽ sinh ra một cái Cookie cho
người âm đây được mã hóa rồi chẳng biết
cái này cái gì ngoài mấy ông ấy hiểu này
gì không Không chả hiểu gì cả em ạ
Ừ cái cái cái này cái copy này nó sẽ lưu
lại trên cái trình duyệt của ông và và
cái này là nó mấy ông sẽ rất khó để biết
được cái này nói gì
Ừ Nếu khó giả rồi Cái này thường là cái
đôi khi còn dài hơn nữa cơ đấy thì cái
này cứ mỗi lần ông ông truy cập cái
trang kia ông sẽ gửi thêm cái key này cả
kèm theo đây cái servo nó nhận diện A
đâu có khi này chứng tỏ ông nào đăng
nhập với tài khoản này sau đó sẽ cho ông
truy cập vào cái tài khoản đấy Đơn giản
thế thôi thế nên là vừa rồi tôi mở bằng
trình duyệt khác em ở ẩn danh ẩn danh
thì nó sẽ không theo quốc kỳ và cũng
tương tự đúng trình duyệt khác nó sẽ
không lấy được Cookie của trình duyệt
kia nên thành ra là tôi sẽ phải đăng
nhập lại và cũng chính vì thế khi mà tôi
đang đăng nhập vào trang Facebook rồi
tôi nhảy sang bất kỳ trang nào khác thì
bản chất Cookie ở trên máy thôi vẫn còn
và cái phiên mở vẫn còn hiệu lực hồi
trước trong Facebook thì nó có cơ chế
khác cơ nó kiểu cứ 15 phút mà không
không hoạt động Ừ thì nó sẽ xóa season
đi để đỡ tốn ram của nó bởi vì lưu trên
server của nó thì sẽ tổn da màu nó nên
nó sẽ thấy season này nó sẽ bị xóa đi
thành ác kia thôi đấy không còn lực nè
tuyển quốc kỳ Vẫn còn nhưng mà không còn
hiệu lực nên nó vẫn phải đăng nhập bạn
còn bây giờ thằng server Facebook của
Mạnh ngồi cho ông treo máy cả ngày cũng
được chạm đăng xuất ông già không ạ ấy
cô kia nó giống thocan tôi từng nói qua
với cái hồi mà chạy grab rồi nên thành
ra mấy ông vẫn đăng nhập được Vào đầy đủ
quyền như bình thường đều Ngoại ok thì
mấy ông vừa rồi vợ biết qua được cái cái
một tí vào cái xin em bây giờ tiếp theo
là ok Bây giờ có bạn biết rồi Ở season
lưu trên server dốc của mình cần lưu lại
những cái gì không ạ Mình cần lưu lại
những cái gì để mà mình đăng nhập vào để
mình luôn kiểm tra được là thằng có
quyền hay không lại vân vân thì
thiết kế bài toán ở đây đó là các bạn
không phải lưu mỗi cái
Anh thường ngồi trước sinh viên của tôi
chơi trò này lưu lại hết toàn bộ thông
tin của người dùng và trong dân chúng ta
đấy Nó rất là thừa và rất là bị ngột ra
chúng ta chỉ nên lưu lại nhấn mạnh tôi
từ này nhé lưu lại trong season
những gì ờ
u2a
Thế Hiển thị dùng từ như thế và là hay
truy vấn chính xác hơn tức là xa ở đây
nha Bây giờ tôi lại vào lại phải bảo lại
Facebook của tôi
tôi bấm vào bất kỳ thời trang nào đây
tôi và tôi và thức ăn nhiều ông ở đây
chắc Smart bị cho em biết qua rồi
khi tôi bấm vào bất kỳ trang nào mấy ông
thử nói tôi biết xem là cái gì Tôi
thường này hiển thị lại khi tôi bận bất
kỳ vào cái trang này
chứ không phải mùi tao diện nhé
ở
trang chủ này không ạ phải trang cá nhân
này
thì tại sao mạng nó bị đâu à Không biết
được bây giờ livestream có với Đây đúng
mày không còn Alo còn lại rất phải nằm ở
tiếng nhỏ nữa cơ Alo Alo ạ
Ê mày không còn ở đây không ạ
à à
ừ ừ
khi phân tích hết
khi Facebook bị Thơ đúng không phải do
hôm nay chính Tôi Mạnh tôi bị đâu không
à à
chứ không phải màn hình đen do Facebook
với đang chết
Ừ ừ thế cho Facebook Chết rồi à
Ừ Vợ tôi đang mở cái tôi tôi mở ti vi en
để thôi Vào trang web ở bên đó
ở bên đối tác ở bên nước ngoài
Ê mày có rồi bây giờ bị mất mạng luôn
cây đây và nhánh Hà Nội đấy thì nếu
không thấy mấy bạn kia rồi ra thời đúng
rồi có bạn vừa chờ được Đúng rồi đó là
ờ ờ
Anh
tên này bà ảnh đại diện ít nhất là như
thế đó thứ thường là xuyên suốt thường
là xương khớp kiểu Các bạn thấy à cứ vào
trước bất kỳ trang nào thì thường hay
hiển thị lại cái ở trên này để cho người
dùng biết được là mình đang đăng nhập
vào tài khoản nào đóng ngoặc tại Khánh
Như thế
không nên ẩn nó đi Bà ngoại là tên là
thậm chí ảnh đại diện nữa không ạ Ở đây
tôi không ảnh đại diện nhưng mà ý nghĩa
là các bạn luôn thì thị tên người dùng
thay vì các bạn cứ mỗi lần và với kỳ
trang nào các bạn lại phải truy vấn
trong B lấy lại tên người dùng mà cái
thứ mà nó lại rất ít khi thay đổi thành
ra là các bạn nên lưu lại nó trong sân
động ngoại
và đôi Và thậm chí đã giống như vừa rồi
mình nói đó là trận chiến lưu lại cả ảnh
đại diện luôn và cho dưới rừng khi thành
danh ở trong cá có nhiều trang của các
bạn để ý các bạn để ý nhá Có nhiều xanh
thì ra cốc nó vẫn còn hơi bị lỗi một tí
đó là khi mà gọi ấn vào thay đổi ảnh đại
diện đấy
Ê thằng Facebook thì đôi khi cũng bị thế
phải các bạn phải tải lại sang thì các
bạn mới thấy hãnh diện các bạn được rồi
còn
thậm chí là các bạn phải đăng xuất ra
vào lại thì các bạn mới thấy tài khoản
ảnh đại diện bị đôi còn không thì có bạn
sẽ vẫn thấy là tại anh đại diện vẫn ảnh
đại diện cũ bởi vì a lưu lại trong sân
Ừ đấy các bạn nếu mà các bạn học cốt rồi
có sẽ hiểu cơ chế nó là như thế
ừ ừ tôi và tắt cái VPN này chắc là mạng
nó bị bất ổn mày Gì mày ông à
em
hẹn giờ tắt hết thiết bị mạng khác
chả thấy ổn hơn rồi đó ạ Tôi thấy sẽ lần
con này Trần Nãy giờ tôi thấy có nhận
trên trang này cho bố vậy Nó bị đo Lát
mình đi
à à
Ừ
thế còn chưa ạ mình vừa thấy hình độ
phân giải kém thì phải không ạ
à à Ừ Ok chắc lại không ổn lắm rồi
Okay tiếp theo nhá tự nhiên em ở phần
này tiếp tiếp theo mà bây giờ nãy giờ
mới làm đi xong 1 cái đăng ký
đề thi thực thực ra là các bạn sẽ phải
lưu lại thêm cái gì trong sân nữa cái
thứ mà người dùng không biết đó là các
bạn sẽ phải lưu lạnh mã của người dùng
vào trong season tại sao như thế bởi vì
như mình đã nói đó là
thì các bạn sẽ phải
khi vẽ phải cậu đăng nhập để mà vào được
tài khoản cá nhân của mình tài khoản cá
nhân của mình trước phải tài khoản của
người khác
Có những thứ để phân biệt tài khoản cá
nhân của mình với tài khoản người khác
nó sẽ phải là cái thứ mà nó duy nhất để
phân biệt về nhau thì nó sẽ thông qua Mã
không ạ Các bạn sẽ có thể nói với mình
đó à
email của anh cũng là duy nhất mà ông ạ
thì email của anh cũng có thể nếu lại để
phân biệt Tại sao anh phải phân biệt quá
Mã làm gì không ạ thường là không ai làm
được lưu lại Email thứ nhất là nó bị dài
dòng hơn mã thứ hai đó là người ta
thường hay làm việc với mã để phân biệt
tài khoản này tao còn kia hơn là và dùng
email đối ngoại
mà Việc Mã thì các bạn sẽ thấy là nó bị
nó bị vấn đề một tí đó là các bạn Insert
xong thì các bạn chưa chắc lấy lực mã
hoặc các bạn sẽ phải sẽ phải xe lách lại
để lấy lại cái mã này nữa nên đoạn này
các bạn sẽ phải thêm một câu xe lách nữa
nó như thế này không ạ Các bạn sẽ lấy
lại
Anh thường là mình sẽ ra snacks sẽ đánh
mắt và để chắc nhất thì có bạn sẽ
slackware chính cái này ngoại Thế tổn
nhất
sao này à
ơi các bạn hãy select ID thôi Được our
email Nha và ổn nhất với rõ ràng email
các bạn không bị chung Nó không biết lo
vấn đề ta có hình nhầm sang ngày đi
người khác không ạ Kết quả đây này
tại đây mình sẽ có
ID
bằng cột hay đi đúng ạ
nha đấy thằng đầu tiên và lấy tại cột ID
của nó sau đó thì đây Mình sẽ lưu lại ID
và trong xuân nha sau A
ừ ừ
em không quay đi để bạn của Summer để
lấy trước
season nó khỏe bạn đâu season họ là
phiên mà khi nó nhập phải không ạ đó như
thế này
ạ bây giờ bởi vì mình không Mình mình có
thể tạo ra một cái trang nhở cho người
dùng cũng được để các bạn xem qua là sử
bây giờ mình sẽ
mình sẽ tạm cái Cha là cha người dùng
thì tại ở bảng Urê đi cũng được không ạ
là như này
là tên màu nâu này
Đây là cha mưa giông
sau đó thì mình có thể là
inna thế cho dù season nêm này lại Mẹ in
tên người dùng I
ở rượu là
Hi
xin chào bạn hay sau đó đi tên người rồi
nếu không hiểu Tôi không ạ ạ
cho
tôi tôi bây giờ Cốt nó dài dòng mà anh
tôi không thể song song 2 màn hình được
nữa thổ nghĩa là tôi tách hẳn ai như thế
này trong mấy ông tôi tát đi tát lại có
thể mấy ông hơi bị đau mắt một tí nhưng
mà nhưng bây giờ sẽ nhìn cốt là rõ hơn
nhá chúng tôi để song song 2 màn hình
cốt nó bị bé tôi tôi nghĩ thế ông ạ Tôi
đăng ký lại phát nữa nhé
nóng hacker 31 lắm hai cơ
lòng hacker
a pro chuyên nghiệp
vip a còng
Chị chuẩn hạng nhà 123 à
Ừ nó tự sướng không ạ bây bây giờ nói
cho bạn đăng nhập xong rồi ông ạ Bây
mình Dạ và b News 1.tp này Xin chào bạn
đấy Các bạn nhớ về vụ này nếu mà các bạn
gặp phải lỗi này chúng tôi ở là nó không
hiểu xin là cái gì ngoại và các bạn sẽ
phải
season pass và mình khuyên các bạn ở nên
nên sự stott Ồ ngay trên cùng thường
người ta cũng làm thế
này xin start Ở mái thiên cung của trang
web không ạ
đó như thế này
là đúng rồi tôi Thiệu trước mắt nữa lại
quên ok đấy như này bé Đăng nhập xong
rồi tôi sẽ dạy các bạn để đăng ký thôi
chứ phải đăng nhập ngoại để đăng nhập vì
thực ra là mấy ông cũng làm phân tử rồng
đăng ký thì tôi làm luôn tôi phải là
năng suất đã không ạ bởi vì lỡ đăng nhập
mất rồi đăng ký vừa rồi kèm vào đăng
nhập rồi ông ạ
à Còn nếu mấy ông lười hơn là mấy ông có
thể chơi trò là đăng ký xong với ông
điều hướng sang trang 5 nhật thường nó
như trang Nó làm như thế dù thường xa
Đăng nhập đăng nhập chứ không đăng nhập
luôn là người dùng như thế này để bắt
người dùng phải điền lại phát nữa cho
người dùng nhớ lại mình đã điền cái gì
không ạ
Đêm Đầu tiên là mình cũng cứ giảm năng
suất đã để người dùng bị văng ra ông ạ
Bây giờ nó nhập rồi mà
ừ ừ
đã đăng xuất rồi à
đừng bỏ rơi tôi dạ dày dép này
tao Trần p không có size boot thì cả nó
giống cái file Delete đấy Ấn vào phát
manga luôn không ạ
ca nhạc trẻ TP này cái này là cái thứ
muốn rất nhiều bạn tôi cảm thấy rất
thích vì file này pha ngắn nhất xin
start là để mà đương nhiên phải làm việc
với Sis phải có xin test không ạ sau đó
tiếp theo xin cho này
nếu là các bạn muốn làm kiểu đơn giản
theo kiểu là tăng xuất và bay hết tất cả
mọi thứ thì sẽ dùng giấy cứ cho nhưng mà
cái này nó không phù hợp với việc là
vì sao các bạn làm rõ hàng thì cái giỏ
hàng rồi nó sẽ lưu lại trong phiên mà
các bạn đang xuất như này các bạn bay
mất luôn cả cái giỏ hàng đấy được là nó
không tốt đấy ạ thì nên là các bạn sẽ
phải dùng cái thứ hai nó ăn xét nhé loại
bỏ những cái thứ các bạn bỏ thôi bạn sẽ
ra cậu ăn xét
sinh tại ai đi ông ạ
à mà nên em ạ
nghĩa là loại bỏ những cái thứ các bạn
cần bỏ thôi
thế này
Vì sao nói về bạn chỉ cần chuyển hướng
quay trở lại thường đăng đăng thường nó
suốt xong người ta có hai hướng một đó
quay trở lại sang Trụ hay quay trở lại
trang đăng nhập
Tôi thường ai quay trở lại trang chủ bởi
vì thường ở chẳng có thằng nào đăng đăng
xuất xong rồi quay trở đăng nhập để mà
đăng nhập cả hãy chuyển như thế
Em bấm vào nhà đó sẽ mang ra ông ạ Bây
giờ tôi Giả sử vào lại cải trang ngu dơ
vừa rồi các bạn sẽ thấy bị lỗi bởi vì
bây giờ thứ nhất là thực là không được
phép vào lại cái trang người dùng nữa Để
mai hiển thị Cái lỗi này đúng ạ thì các
bạn sẽ có kiểm tra ở đây đó là nếu mà
không không có season nóng ạ Chính xác
là có season nhưng mà không có season ai
đi họ không có season nêm thì bạn sẽ đều
không quay trở lại thường mà tôi sẽ cho
kiểu như mà không có xin ID chả thế tôi
sẽ băng ra bạn ạ
à à thì mình sẽ còn tăng giá như thế này
nó cái Index trên pc không ạ Alo lại
đăng nhập đi bạn này
là Thôi để sáng hành trang và đăngnhập
đi
hình ảnh này anh nhờ file này cho tạo
đang báo lỗi không ạ
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia nói đúng đó là season
thì tắt Chrome mà mất
nhưng mà cốc cái thì các bạn ạ oke nó
cũng có thời gian hiệu lực nhé Nó ngoại
oke vẫn thời gian hiệu lực Anh thường
cái season nó sẽ chỉ làm và thận chết
Chrome đôi khi nóng chạy ngầm nữa lại
cho cái bài toán thì cái việc à
Cậu Các bạn bảo là tắt máy tắt tắt đi
thì thoảng cũng phải trang web nó vẫn
phải yêu cầu đăng nhập lại không ạ bởi
vì cái xinh nó hết hạn
khi đó ngoại section
như mình đã nói sẽ dần vẫn có thể hết
hạn trong một khoảng thời gian không
chuyện không tưởng bác này nó sẽ dần ở
trên server đó không thể hết hạn và cái
cô kia qua bạn sẽ không còn hiệu lực
hoặc chính cái Cookie để nó sẽ được xét
phải có bao nhiêu thời gian hết hạn ở
đây này bạn xem lại
công tác đội
anh ơi bịt con này quá nóng coi
ở đây bạn thấy thời gian hết hạn lại bao
giờ bao giờ này không ạ
cho nó hết hạn thì nó sẽ không đăng nhập
được nữa thôi không ạ ạ
khi
bé mình làm phải đăng nhập nhé á
am7 này a form
nghe này thì hôm nay có khi phải lên đấy
nữa hai tiếng đấy Vậy còn chưa dậy rồi
kể chứ nói về bộ khách cùng gì 9 rưỡi
rồi
ngoài giỏi phết
nghe tôi nghĩ vài ông sẽ bị
vợ kế hoạch không ạ đăng nhập này ạ
khi
mua xe ô tô settle in ngoại p a
ý
tưởng ngay tới quyền xử lý email vừa nãy
thôi email dài quá
xe máy melt
từ nãy giờ tôi không hề mã hóa nên từ ca
nó khá nguy hiểm Ngoại Tôi từng nói vụ
này nó lập trình riêng mà và nhìn tắt
quất thì chết
pro có một cái
0123 đóng ạ
khi đăng nhập không kiểu gì tội sẽ chia
sẻ thôi Sợ chị lúc đấy mày ông nào hết
thôi
hứa phải làm đúng không ạ tôi vẫn còn
như thời gian lắm
thì
mình sẽ có email bằng đô la Push email
im
a password
giai đoạn này có thể copy nhanh ở bên
này được thì các bạn sẽ thấy copy nhanh
ở cái đoạn này
ở Huế phải thích đoạn này tí đoạn này là
à
đã kết nối đóng ạ các bạn sẽ đếm xem mà
có bạn ghi nào có chung email và mật
khẩu phải không này à
ở
nơi này sung nếu nếu mà ở đây sẽ xuất
hiện 2 tình huống ạ Nếu mà còn 5 pro
bằng bằng một cái là có chung đúng không
ạ thì mình sẽ mình sẽ thử tạo sẽ thử nó
nó thôi và thành công nóng
ung thư và tôi sẽ làm như này hơn sẽ lúc
sao luôn ở đây sẽ ra mình sẽ
Ừ bye bye đợi nằm ở đâu bằng mic i i i
à à Nằm proud
Âm Nhạc
35 Châu
tại đây
đoạn này tức là sao mình sẽ lấy toàn bộ
thông tin khách hàng theo email và mật
khẩu đã đăng nhập vào hiếm mà rồi mình
đếm xem có bao nhiêu bạn ghi nếu mà một
chắc là có bản ghi rồi thì mình sẽ có
Sistar này
này tao đó thì mình sẽ lưu vào trong sân
thôi Ai đi này
ở
đôla
Vietsub
không Bây giờ mình sẽ phải có lợi ích
bằng Michael mình cần lấy thằng đầu tiên
nữa thử cái hành ủy sốt cho nó lợi ích
tại vị trí ID này cái loại nên này
sau đó mình sẽ điều hướng
dokyson
sẽ sang trang news.va p thẳng ạ
axit chứ còn nếu mà sai thì sao Nếu mà
Ở đây các bạn mua đồ dùng Eo chắc hay là
các bạn thấy ở rõ là cốt nó chạy đúng là
đoạn này nó
có một axit ở đây rồi thì không thì ở
dưới này các bạn axit luôn thất bại cũng
được
nhưng này cũng được thì vì đoạn này nó
sẽ nhắc lại ngay dẫn đây mình có thành
công rồi
gì sai sai này mình sẽ thêm để Alo không
ạ
khi đăng nhập sai rồi em ạ
tay mình sẽ thử đăng nhập sai trước đi
ngày này đăng nhập đây đó các bạn thấy
nó sẽ đăng nhập sai rồi tôi thử đăng
nhập đúng không ạ Chị sẽ là hai cơ rồi
Một hai bạn đó ok
bộ đồ chơi đấy đầy đủ qua về cái đăng ký
đăng xuất mà đăng nhập
anh cũng tương đối ạ Các bạn thế là thơ
ca là cốt nó nãy giờ được là không hẳn
nó dài lắm không gặp mẹ dài mỗi file nó
tầm 2 mấy dòng Thôi
hai mấy dòng không ạ
Có phải lên được 30 dòng mày Ông thấy
tôi em tôi nhiều mà Bọn tôi xuống rằng
nhiều mấy ông nhìn rõ cốt cốt nói thì
trông ngắn hơn tí không ạ ạ
Ừ nhưng mà đại khái nó như thế đó tôi
vừa dạy qua cho mày ông ghê đăng kýđăng
nhập
I told chuyện có chung mục nhanh không
Béo ngấy rồi
thì chính về cái vụ hôm nay tôi dậy được
mấy ông phải cái đăng ký đăng nhập như
thế thành ra là kiểu bây giờ còn liên
quan đến vụ khách khách khủng thì mình
sẽ dễ hiểu về vấn đề hơn ngoại đầu tiên
cho xứ dậy Ông mấy ông về cái khái niệm
is
dạy qua vài khái niệm thôi Còn tôi à Tôi
chưa để mua cho méo vụ đấy hôm nay
Ừ cái nói đại khái như thế này đó là khi
mà kiểu chạy cái bản chất nó sẽ chè thì
ra Switch và chuyến trang nào đó mà
người dùng kia nó sẽ người dùng này nó
sẽ nghĩ cậu thực hiện cái hack đấy nó sẽ
kiểu như này
anh trai ra sự khó hay đang chat với
nhau những giờ bình thường như thế này
này
à à ở đó
sau đó thì lần này có bạn kia bạn đấy
Kiểu thấy thằng này đang đăng nhập vào
và muốn lấy tài khoản của tháng này
chính xác một lấy Cookie gì Thằng này Ok
như tôi vừa nói cô kia sẽ được lễ hội
chứng chính trình duyệt và có thể có thể
dùng ra Swift phải lấy được cái Coffee
đấy anh ra là thằng này nó sẽ xem cái
đoạn ra Speed vào
ở đầu tiên họ sẽ trở thành thử ra Speed
kiểu như này để xem chạy được không thì
các bạn thấy ra chút ít và chạy được
mạnh chất là cái trang web kia nó không
hề nó không hay kiểu giống như vậy tôi
nói đó là kiểu thêm cái kiểu loại bỏ ký
tự đặc biệt thành ra kiểu khi lại in ra
cái tin nhắn này dùng pp hay dùng bất kỳ
ngôn ngữ lập trình duyệt ra tin nhắn bản
chất nói ra đúng HTML còn nôi mà không
thể kiểm tra kí tự đặc biệt tại nhtm
thuần ở đây trong trường hợp này in ra
hẳn ra Switch và ra Spain nó chạy được
luôn với trình giờ hiểu Đấy ra Swift
đang chạy được luôn vừa rồi mới thử vụ
lót bình thường nhưng bây giờ là thấy có
vẻ chạy được cái này Hacker sẽ chèn thêm
là nó sẽ điều hướng thời trang hack của
hai cơ thể chèn thêm cái đoạn là lấy cái
Cookie của người dùng như thế này ý
nghĩa sẽ gửi quốc kỳ người dùng đến cái
chai hacker kia đấy trông thấy thế có
nghĩa là những em ấy ông chỉ cần vào cái
trang nào đó không cần bấm và đừng Vinh
thì nó lại không ạ mày không nhận được
tin nhắn người khác
ờ Mà mà cái Trang đấy mà nó không bảo
mật Trang đấy cậu để lỗ hổng về xs kiểu
như thế là người dùng của toàn bộ mày
thấy trang web này rất bị nguy hiểm đóng
lại những cách ép này nó tấn công mà là
hình thức tấn công
từ từ
vụ tấn công vào khách hàng của cái trang
web đấy chứ không phải tấn công ở trang
web ấy cái Vũ hết này ngoài cái vũ khí
chết nó có thể liên quan được là như tôi
vừa dậy với cái việc là đăng nhập cái
ngọn season của mấy ông là do sự mấy ông
đang chặn đăng nhập vợ chồng web vào đó
không ạ Mấy ông ạ
à à
Lê Mận mì ông có thể có cái vụ này xảy
ra nữa để cho mày không xem nó tải cho
mấy ông xem cái
tự nhiên trang này dậy cả hack cách
phòng chống như mấy ông xem qua về cách
phòng chống sau nhé
bây giờ sự mấy ông thầy có con mèo dễ
thương là sự trong như này trong Luyện
rất là bình thường như ông muốn tưởng có
thể bấm ở đây thì phát phát được đi ông
ạ Hồi trước bầu miễn dịch nhá đầy thấy
mình cái ảnh không ạ Người ta bấm mà nó
một đường link virus thôi ạ
ở Nghệ An lúc đầu nó sẽ có khái niệm
iPhone mà như thế này ăn chè thêm cái
kiểu một cái một cái ảnh sau đó thì nó
sẽ chèn thêm cái đoạn
chị xem thêm một cái cậu xét ẩn nào đi
bản chất nó thể a a cho nó sẽ nhảy sang
thì cái trong cách mạng lớp của nó khi
mình bấm vào cái nhìn trong người rất
bình thường này sau đó mình bấm vào cái
này để mà kiểu cố xem được cái lý do ai
lập tức là sẽ nhảy sang cái tra mã độc
kia thì cái cái này nó có thể gây nguy
hiểm được à hồi hồi trước có cái vụ
ở đó lý do mà tôi từng nói mấy ông đã
không nên để mấy tốt làm ấy rất ghét mà
Để lên form nên để mới support về Hồi
trước mình nhớ không lầm đã từng có cái
vụ Nó kiểu như thế này là sự đây một
trăng Ngân hàng nào đó là bank.com như
này chẳng hạn ông ạ trà sữa ông năng ông
ông có đang đăng nhập vào tài khoản trên
trang mạng trang Bank này tớ không cần
để đăng nhập lại nữa là bọn đấy bây bây
giờ sự là kiểu tự nhiên là cái trang
upanh.com này có cái file mà file chuyển
tiền chấp em ạ
sau đó thì nó sẽ có thêm là à mã người
nhận ạ
bằng một à bằng như thế này
số
và số tiền bằng được sự chăm nha à
xe tải thằng hacker nó lừa ông bấm vào
lực Linh này chẳng hạn thế Tự nhiên à
Ông chuyển tiền cho cái thằng có mã nhìn
này
anh đánh chậm như này ta là chết đấy do
là mấy ông không bao giờ nên có cái
anh không không bao giờ nên có cái kẹo
made là mấy thuốc ghét bạn nên làm ad
post Bởi vì nếu ở mấy thấy ghét thì hãy
rất dễ bị hack không ạ nhưng bấm nó được
linh kiện ngay lập tức ông chuyển tiền
đó thắng nào đó nhưng mà đương nhiên cái
này Nếu không bảo Ok thì bây giờ em để
mấy thớt post đó sẽ không còn gì cái
trường hợp này không ạ Vẫn không hạn
ạ bây giờ nó vẫn là cái đường link này
Ok mới thật là lại mới thấy tốt rồi nó
sẽ dùng ra Suite vẫn có thể gọi được đến
cái cái đường link này và chen nó là mấy
thấp ghét hả Mỹ thớt post vẫn chưa được
dẫn truyền được với cái thông tin được
như vừa rồi mấy rất tốt vẫn chưa được mã
người nhận
vẫn bằng một được và số tiền chuyển vẫn
là bằng bằng một trang được vẫn bình
thường thì thì trong trường hợp Lần này
thì chúng ta vậy phòng chống nóng nhà đó
lý do mà được các ngân hàng sẽ thêm cái
OTP hoặc thêm cái một cái mã nó nó nữa
gửi với email họ tin nhắn hoặc cả một
cái mã tạm hồi nào đó gọi là sheriff
Ừ Ok
Có cái đoạn này cái đoạn này nó sẽ sinh
ra ngẫu nhiên của mỗi cái form tiền mà
tránh việc hacker có thể biết được cái
tô kem này bởi vì nó ngẫu nhiên
Anh và mỗi cái phom đấy khi các bạn đăng
nhập vào bạn sẽ thấy à Không bình thường
các bạn sẽ kiểu không không hề biết cái
này nó nằm trong thời phong đấy nha các
bạn căn cho new thì có bạn sẽ thấy cái
cái mã đấy có khá nhiều trang web bây
giờ vẫn còn đang dùng để có chế đấy mình
thử trang như anh Tuấn cũng đang dùng
ghichu
a teen.net ạ
ạ bây giờ cần nhờ cơ chế chung một cái
Facebook thường ai có thêm cả cái đoạn
bạn đầy rồi
cho tôi đang cho ta nhé đăng nhập lại
anh ạ
à à
ở đây tôi gõ cho kèn
à Tại mấy ông thầy cô chen để có tóc em
nghe này bạn nó sẽ ra cậu sinh em ngẫu
nhiên không ai biết được cái thì cái
đoạn này là để hacker không Dạ được và
bất kỳ cái phone nào post nó đều phải
thêm cái thêm cái Token này nữa để mà
thấy cơ không Dạ được cái đoạn để mà làm
được cái hình thức này triệu hồi trước
là từng có khá nhiều ngân hàng bị hack
vụ này rồi đấy bởi vì người dùng đăng
nhập mà người dùng Đăng nhập thành ra là
không cần kiểm tra lại người dùng đã
đăng nhập
Ừ đúng ạ chỉ cần gọi được đến đường link
đấy theo người dùng đang Ai nhập là có
ngờ là
được hoàn thành giao dịch rồi và có
nhiều người dùng mất tiền à không ạ đi
a tiếp theo nói nốt về cái vụ này vụ này
chính ở vụ mặt tôi vừa dậy mà ông về vụ
đăng nhập luôn đây mấy ông thử nhé
Ừ nếu không thấy rõ ràng là cái cụ Pháp
vừa rồi nó rất là dễ kia trở lại
khi bé thử đăng nhập bằng kiểu thể đăng
nhập vào cái gì đó
thì đó là mật khẩu ngay các thứ thứ in
nào nha anh đăng nhật nhưng không thấy
sẽ vào đăng nhập lần này thất bại không
ạ Nó sẽ luôn bảo lỗi chung chung là
email vào đăng nhập mật khẩu không hợp
lệ không ạ Nhưng bây là lần này tôi sẽ
nhập mật khẩu 123 ngay tôi tự nhiên tôi
thêm cái dấu nháy này
ai dọn nhái này các bạn với hiểu là nháy
nó là gì Nó là kiểu đầu với ra tội nó
rồi Cái nháy này nó là các kí tự đặc
biệt nó kết thúc Trỗi không ạ sẽ bảo một
cái lỗi đưa ngân hàng sẽ bảo lỗi nghe
lời này Nó lỗi không liên quan lỗi là
email và mật khẩu không hợp lệ mà không
nên sẽ bao giờ lỗi là cái lỗi chung ngay
bởi vì nội dung Chung này nó sẽ xảy ra
khi mà khi mà kẹo cái câu truy vấn của
ông khiến cho cái xử lý nó bị lỗi Thế
lần này đây mình sẽ xử lý nó là như thế
nào
sau khi mà bị lỗi này xảy ra tất cả chỉ
ra cái thằng lập trình viên nó không hề
xử lý cái cây ký tự đặc biệt nhàng ra là
mình nhập bất kỳ cái gì khác
để mà sửa lại câu truy vấn SQL đều được
lần này mình sẽ Các bạn thấy bây lần này
tôi nhập bất kỳ cái email của một người
bất kỳ sao tôi sẽ thêm à
Em email và đương nhiên phải đúng nhá
sau đó thêm nhái này ko U1 = 1 sau đó
Cái gì
12 dấu ủ như này đăng nhập này
ở đó sẽ đăng nhập được vào ngoại rồi tôi
đăng nhập email linh tinh chàng này chỉ
cho demo nó đăng nhập ngay thôi như các
bạn thấy bạn chất cái câu chuyện lần này
Tại sao nó xảy ra như thế Vì ạ Các bạn
nhớ về câu
Cho tôi mở trong mấy ông xem nhé á
Ừ tôi sẽ Thủ Đoàn cầu siêu chuẩn ở
chương trình Cái chai của mình vừa rồi
đi để ông xem qua câu trích dẫn
ở nơi này là tôi sẽ thông báo đó đăng
nhập thành công vào đăng nhập bạn đi ừ
ừ ừ
à à
xe tăng xuất nhé
em về đăng nhập này à
I say nóng nhỉ
Ê hồi sáng tạo Vậy à
Ừ Ok bây giờ sự tôi à
Anh không quan tâm email rồi tôi không
ăn được email email thanh tịnh được lắm
chứ tôi xóa cái mèo bị được xóa mũi
email định được nhé
e61 email đi này tôi chỉ cần là quan tâm
với mật khẩu Thôi cứ đổi mật khẩu là
cho tôi tôi để cho mật khẩu cho mấy ông
dễ nhìn tí nhé Thứ nhất là tôi tạm tắt
autocomplete đi cho mày cũng được khó
chịu Nó cũng thấy thông báo ra là tôi để
hai nó là tách để cho mấy ông dễ nhìn
xem tôi đã nhập cái gì nhé á
Ừ hai mẹ ông thấy không Tự động điện nữa
đây để tôi thử
em nhập như lai giống như vừa rồi của nó
to một vòng 11 bằng một tất cả luôn đúng
không ạ sống như này thôi cậu bé ông như
lại được thăng hoặc là như này chứ đều
biến cái đoạn cốt đằng sau bên chú thích
xe tải đăng nhập
ừ nóng thấy đoạn này lỗi Tại sao bởi vì
à
ở cái đoạn này nó là tao sao email bằng
Email này password bằng 1 bằng 1
Ừ nhưng phải cắt ra tất cả
I believe in
khi bật lại thì ai nhựa tăng thằng này
rồi nó thằng đi ừ
Ê thằng này đó
Ê thằng cũng được cái thuộc kia cũng
được tôi tôi thường anh dùng Xong rồi
biển tất cả mọi thứ đang sau này chụp
đích này Anh nghe rồi nháy là không có
tính nữa thành ra là đoạn cốt của tôi
thực ra Nó chỉ có nhắn như thế thôi bỏ
qua rồi ngày này ông thấy ạ khi mà cái
xử lý password nói chuyện vào nó là cả
cái đoạn này đúng không ạ Và nó cái cái
thang này khiến nó dấu nháy không không
còn hợp đây thành ra câu truy vấn của
tôi sẽ là email bằng bằng cái dấu chấm
hoặc cả mật khẩu bằng dấu chấm hoặc một
bằng 10 ạ một bằng 1 thì nó luôn Đúng
cái O này nó làm cho toàn bộ cái dự cái
trước nó không có nghĩa thì kiểm tra nữa
nhưng lần này May mà lần này vẫn đang
nhập sai rồi bởi vì sao Bởi vì lần này
tôi có kiểm tra thêm là Anh chỉ được một
bản ghi thôi và cái vụ Đăng thấy sẽ
lexar này của tôi vừa rồi Nó lại trả về
tận rất nhiều Bạn ghi anh phải ra May mà
mai mai mà không không vào được thử nhé
ở tại tôi copy hết cả dòng máy rồi Không
xem à
A chạy
khi đó nó sẽ trả về hết như này nhưng mà
bây giờ tôi cũng có thêm một cách nữa đó
tôi thể cho thêm Limit một ở đây nữa để
chắc chắn chỉ Chào mừng một hành vi đó
cho nó nghiệp thành công thế xong đấy
nếu mà khi mà ông không kiểm tra khi mà
không kiểm tra cái gì
300 kiểm tra việc lạ nhập ký tự đặc biệt
vào
không ạ Thịnh thành thành ra là cậu của
nó có thể
khách hack được mày cái ít ai quen rất
xinh Dạo này để đăng nhập được Vào trang
web của mấy ông
Mạnh khi mấy ông sẽ phải kiểm tra mình
cái vụ người dùng nhặt luôn luôn phải
bay đến kiểm tra mấy cái vụ đấy
à à
ở
buổi nào hướng dẫn về tại phần comment
hay đánh rắm xong xong không Mình chưa
dậy về cái vụ đấy
Ừ cái đấy không trước mình nói tích mà
nó sao ấy trong đồ án đấy thì ra các bạn
vẫn thể nhiều cách làm hồi trước tôi làm
đi cầu cũng để tiện đi đỡ phải ngồi nghĩ
tính năng nhiều nguồn tạo ra bây giờ nói
thì
cái này gọi lại quen Jackson nó liên
quan nó tiên mã độc ekul về mà làm được
khách cùng với thử thứ thể truy cập được
vào trang web này hay thậm chí ở không
là phải vài buổi nữa Có thể tôi sẽ dạy
mày ông có thể dùng trứng cái trang Nếu
nghĩ rằng lại em quen Jackson nó chỉ
liên quan đến việc đăng nhập bác không
giờ sửa tôi có trang có cái thùng cái
tìm kiếm ở đây ạ
ở các béo nhớ vụ tìm kiếm không ạ Hãy
tôi sẽ hack từ cả cái thanh tìm kiếm để
màn hiển thị thông tin của admin ở ngay
trên trang chủ luôn cũng được tí do địa
chỉ em mấy ông à Không để buổi sau nhé
Vì sao bộ cháu nữa nha buổi sau đi tôi
hẳn rồi nhé
ý mày sao tao dễ dãi mày ông về cái vụ
khách được thanh tìm kiếm
có một vài chào bây giờ vẫn còn gì đấy
Nói thế không phải tôi khuyên mày ông ở
nên làm nên làm đâu nhé
300 bảo tôi dại Miu người đấy chết à
cả nhà buổi xong nữa tôi sẽ chị mày ông
về à ở buổi hôm nay ở bộ thứ mấy nhà Đỗ
Mai buổi thứ ba đúng không đủ thứ bảy
tôi sẽ chịu mấy ông về
đồ án 1 của tôi nha sẽ cho ông xem qua
về cái đó một Tôi đã làm những cái gì
không ạ
à à
ờ ờ Nếu mà bạn mới tham gia
i10 mới tham gia đăng ký tạo làm đỏ theo
nhóm thì các bạn sẽ được lùi đất này một
tuần so với các nhóm trước nhé không
Không cần phải chạy deride kịp cùng các
bạn kia đâu
à À đấy Tôi không hiểu tại sao có khá
nhiều bạn đăng ký Sau đó nhiều bạn không
thể nhắn tin gì đó cho tôi không biết
được cả mấy ông mấy bạn đấy chắc không
để ý cái phần mô tả hay bình luận của
tôi khối video là tôi Tôi cần mấy bạn
đấy Kiểu vào loạn discord nó cả đăng ký
đầu An không ạ đi
Ừ khổ kêu gọi tôi gửi mail trong mấy bạn
đấy anh như bị rơi hết vào thư mục spam
rồi chạy bây giờ inbox riêng mình mấy
bạn bên Facebook gan nó cũng sẽ bạn giờ
tôi 1 span thôi
ở nhà chắc à
anh trầm tôi sẽ xem xét Kêu gọi mấy ông
đấy như nào Thế bây giờ người ta tội hơi
bị lười hôm trước hỏi tôi chấm cho tận
ba mấy nhóm mất sự mất 23 tiếng
anh cũng khác bị lừa bây giờ mà thêm
nhiều nhóm đông quá người ta là cũng
phải lùi nó ra này bảo vệ những buổi sau
nữa
Xin
chào trước mắt tôi có giải quyết Mày cài
nhóm đang xanh tôn nặng đã sau đó thì
tôi sẽ liên hệ những các bạn Phía Sau Em
à à Bạn đang nói về tình về cái Tân
quyền không ạ phân quyền của bên admin
và Superman mình sẽ dậy sau nhé
Ừ đúng rồi tôi Tôi quên mất bây giờ tôi
sẽ dạy nốt mấy ông về cái get nhé
U15 mới vào thể đăng ký đây tôi quên lại
thôi để cho mấy ông để lên đăng ký cái
này là cái gì à
à à
ở đây tôi tôi tôi sẽ chỉ mấy ông phải
cái get cách dùng beat nhanh thôi đấy
treo cách tôi dùng nhé Và tôi từ ra tôi
từng nói là tôi thấy nó không chuyên hạn
với get thế này ra tôi không để dậy mấy
ông chi tiết cũng như không có thể họ sẽ
hơi bị xa có thể nó sẽ sai không biết
sai không nghe mà theo như ý do hiểu nó
sẽ như thế đây bây giờ đầu tiên thì các
bạn lên cái trang biết hát cũng các bạn
đúng không ạ Tôi từng nói rồi các bạn sẽ
tạo một cái Zippo
ông ạ Các bạn sẽ tạo một cái Zippo trên
này Đấy sau đó thì các bạn sẽ
anh sẽ giả sự có một cái cấm cả như này
đi đường link này các bạn sẽ
bây giờ tôi thấy nó có rất là nhanh tiện
rồi các bạn đầu tiên các bạn à Tải cái
get hấp cái top này tôi đang dùng cái
ghi thắp Laptop này thì sang cái khác à
ở đây sau đó các bạn ấn cốt này sợ
open-ended hát Laptop này nó sẽ mở lên
cho các bạn cho các bạn chỉ việc Grow nó
về vẻ như thế này khi mà con non về
sau khi mặc Clone về như thế này thì các
bạn sẽ giờ sự tối của lòng về uống xem
cho con về như thế này thì bị ông sẽ
thấy có khái niệm là đầu tiên thì nó sẽ
có khái niệm về friend mày không hiểu
quen và Cậu nháy như thế này nó có thể
là thử cái ông làm việc theo ít người
được mời cũng chỉ quan tâm việc có ngáy
của ông một cái nhánh Master là master
và nhánh đều là nhánh hiệu nhánh chung
ngành chuẩn nhất rồi theo kiểu là mày
ông cốt sẽ ghét hết tốt vào cốt chuẩn
vào trong cái ngành này còn mấy ông
thường mày tạo hình ảnh riêng như thế
này được sự nhánh của tôi thêm những
Long chẳng ạ để tạo hàm một cái nhánh
riêng kiện ngay đó sau đó thì tôi sẽ
ở cốt bất kỳ cái gì vào trong cái trong
các thư mục này là sự tôi cốt để ngay đi
mở thư mục lên nhé
để tạo một file mới này
a demo chắn ATM này
tôi lưu lại thì mày Ông mở lại cái này
lên lập tức là nó sẽ đề xuất cho mấy ông
ngoại sẽ đầy cái đoạn cốt nào đó lên như
này thì mới ông hoàn toàn khi mà Mấy ông
đẩy cốc lên đấy thì mấy ông nên lưu ý đó
là mấy ông nên ghi cái Chú thích sao cho
tôi Hồi trước tôi xem cách ghi Chủ Đích
rất là hay Tôi thấy mấy ông hôm trước
tôi xem thử mấy ông có mấy ông đã dùng
ít trong mấy ông ghi chú thích thật ra
không tốt Tôi không biết được là mấy ông
ghi cho có vậy bởi vì a đang cũng không
cần là Hà Nội chuyên nghiệp lắm Nhưng mà
nếu thực sự với ông muốn chứng nhiệt
cách ghi sổ thích mà thôi thường tôi hồi
trước tôi đọc được trên VIP vibro cái
ghi chú thích nó sẽ như thế này à
ờ ờ nếu không sẽ thường hay có tôi tôi
nhớ là nó sẽ có có vài cái đầu tiên này
khái niệm apdate này phát tơ này
free format này và Pixel rồi
có tiền update tất cả để cập nhật đồ
ngọn vì vector sẽ làm chị lại
thay đổi khá nhiều về cốt các cậu là
thay thay hẳn đổi cơ chế kiểu cốt Đang
xử lý bài toán là theo kiểu hướng này tự
nhiên nhảy hạn Sang hướng khác nghĩa
không chỉ là nó update là cập nhật một
vài cái nữa bạn thay đổi hẳn thì cơ chế
thì sẽ dùng Cài khái niệm phí Pasteur
format tất cả chỉ để mà kẹo cần nhớ đệm
A cậu thay đổi giao diện hoặc là thay
đổi về kiểu mấy cái dòng cốt nên cái Tab
vào hay là kiểu đổi tên biến từ thứ nó
cậu và format tới Dạ hắn chỉ ra kẹo hiển
thị
về mặt em còn về cậu cất kỹ thuật thì
không có ý
a tiếp theo là Future tức là các bạn làm
hạn thêm tính năng mới để các bạn sẽ ghi
theo kiểu tạo Thủy Châu đây sau đó thì
nó sẽ là gì Bạn sẽ Tôi thường ngày thêm
cái rốn tròn như thế này sau đó bình
trong nó làm mô tả qua về việc thêm cái
gì đó là sợ là
Ừ tôi sẽ bảo thêm á
à à Giả sử vừa rồi nha là sự vừa rồi là
làm đăng ký đúng không làm đăng ký sẽ là
apsy này
anh em
Sign and sign up and
size chỗ nào đó sau đó thì các bạn sẽ
ghi hai chấm rồi Tiếp theo là cái cái
lớn từ lớn đến bé đến cái rượu cái phần
mà các bạn làm và xử phạt làm phần bên
admin à hãy làm phần Minh khách hàng lại
Vân là sự đây là sự bên customer này
gạch ngang ngay họ sửa lỗi Liên quan đến
đăng nhập không ạ size nha Chẳng hạn đó
đây đầy đủ đầy đủ của cái khi mà tôi mấy
cái dưới này nóng tương tự thôi các bạn
sẽ thấy một trò như này thôi Bạn ghi vào
thì khi các bạn đẩy cái đoạn này lên đầy
đoạn này lên để các bạn xem cái thì các
bạn chưa Một thường là lập trình viên
khi mà xem việc là người kia lại cốt
những cái gì sẽ thể xem thêm cậu ạ
khi đánh sẽ ấn vào
Anh tên của cái người kia đầy lên thông
tin nhanh là gì sau đó là mới xem đến
cốt thì thì hoàn toàn là người ta xem
được hình dung được là mấy ông đã có cái
gì
tìm kiếm mô tả qua về cả những cái cốt
của âm trước khi đọc code của mấy ông
đấy
Nói chung là khi đẩy lên Xong là sự đẩy
lên kiểu khi con Mỹ song đó ngọn đẩy khi
mà không ít xong là chưa đẩy lên nhé Để
ông sẽ phải cọp phút nó lên bê tôi vì
tôi chưa có Brit cái cặp gen này lên
thành nha chưa có khái niệm phút
khi bé đầu tiên à khi mà lúc đầu nó chạy
luôn Hỏi mua Rooney password nè Chưa cần
được user name và password của ông thôi
là được đấy
ở trong khi phút xong rồi thì à còn nói
chung vào thêm khái niệm nữa như sau nó
khái niệm mà kéo Cốt về nữa có khái niệm
là ông âm thường ấy ông âm thường là ông
đẩy cốt lên thôi họ sẽ dễ bị kiểu có
khái niệm là con Flex
với cái cốt người khác thế là kiểu bị bị
xung đột với cốt người khác là sự cả hai
người cùng sửa cùng 1 file cùng một dòng
thì nó sẽ bị à con dốc thức là nó bị
xung đột cốt Bởi vì khi mà ghép vào Rốt
cuộc là thằng kia chả biết nhận được
dòng cốt của thằng chuẩn không ạ đây thì
các bạn thường là các bạn khi đẩy cốt
lên không phải để luôn như thế mà các
bạn sẽ khái niệm mà còn nhảy sang Master
như này các bạn sẽ ấn fake để lấy code
mới show Phu Kéo Cốt về sau đó các bạn
và lại bên mắt vào lại bên như này được
các bạn sẽ chọn là update for Master như
thế này em nhập code mới nhất từ bến
Master sau đó thì các bạn mới
các bạn Nếu mà thấy có cái khái niệm can
speak là nếu có sinh sông nộp gì đây các
bạn sửa cái xung đột đây đã tôi các bạn
mới đẩy cốc lên xôi đầy xong để xong
trên nhánh các bạn rồi nhé Còn sẽ lại
bên quay lại bên Master rồi có bạn sẽ
update sẽ bớt cốt từ từ cái ngành này
vào sau mình ngày Master các bạn để mày
lấy cút mới sau đó các bạn phút lên để
đẩy Q10 lên để không ạ vì nó khá lằng
nhằng như thế nhưng mà chính vì như thế
nó lại xa chuyên nghiệp theo kiểu đó các
bạn sẽ sửa chi nhánh các bạn không ảnh
hưởng đến các nhánh chính nhánh chính
thì chạy vẫn rất ổn nhàng các bạn có vấn
đề gì có bạn xưởng bên các bạn thôi Khi
mà chắc chắn ổn hết rồi Khi mà xong hẳn
một tính năng rồi các bạn sẽ
đẩy hết lên hành chính ngoãn và nhanh
trí lấy cốt nó sẽ không được chuyện xung
đột thì mấy ông ạ
Ừ ok đại phá mình biết hoa cơ bản và
mình gửi anh ở công ty mày anh ấy cũng
trị tương đối mình thế thôi anh ra là
mình cũng không
anh không biết chia sẻ thêm cái gì
khi cài đặt quân đội mình nghĩa tương
đối rồi
10 bản chất là tôi cũng không không ngờ
có lệnh Để mà giải thích
mấy ông thật ra có thể nếu mà ông muốn
hiểu rõ hơn Nguyên hóa thực ra mấy ông
có thể hiểu à
Xin chào về cách hướng dẫn cốt hòa cũng
trước tôi có chia sẻ cái
cái của thấy thầy Xuân đấy
để mà hướng dẫn tôi get Còn tôi thì thôi
Chị biết mỗi thế thôi
à à
Ừ tôi có biết nữa mới có lệnh các thứ từ
đâu Hiện tại thì nó vẫn ổn không ạ
anh ra 8 giờ đánh hỏi bây giờ 40 7:40
vào xem tâm sự đấy
Ừ Ok chắc là tặng thấy thế thôi nhỉ
Ừ
tao mới thế thôi chắc À hôm nay kết thúc
đây hơn hai tiếng rồi làm chả các bạn
nhé Có gì cứ bình luận bình bình luận
hỏi hỏi đáp sau nhé Chào bạn nhé